[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i might check my check
what is going around
talk to me right quick
we got a nice one lined up for you today
it is your host lord cognito
here on the sunday the lord's day
appropriately
[Music]
what's going on hi max what's up
see you football season upon us
my god man yo i appreciate the love
support we outside early
i see the videos that's a lot of love
brother you already know
gaming forte hey forte what's going on
now i'm omar the homie lydian master
what's going on tim pearl what's up
necromancer's sale what's going on
christopher hart you're on time that's
what i want to see
what's going on we got a phone man
supposedly the legend hopefully led you
to come through this would be fun
and uh talk to the people right quick
the lords are pulling up you know saying
how to close out right now
atomic sands what's going on
i see you a little tired today we got a
big show we got a big show what a crazy
week
we got a big show some great topics
james morrison what's going on i see you
so we're gonna wait for the legend to
get in here
you know oh you can't be late for the
audio video version of the all right
today
we're gonna wait for the legend to get
up in here
throw the crest up we'll show them some
love
we're gonna talk to a legend in the game
ham solo what's up i see you great
birthday weekend okay happy boring day
death singer what's going on bro i see
you in a minute fuzzy what's going on
blam crew and them
that's what's up the car master my guy
lawyer metroid attacking the building
salute everybody pulling up that's
what's up man we got some fun show
great topics lined up
trying to get the legend up in here
jason rubin y'all this is legendary this
the accomplishments hopefully we get the
chance to talk
and uh really dive deep into some things
in the past and in the future kurt
what's going on
so look i'm gonna go make sure
everybody's good
go see what's up with the rest of the
lords and uh yeah we gotta go i'll talk
a bit
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
um
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah i
be eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is
[Applause]
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want wanna compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you were messaging people
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social my city but i'm still by
coastal
[Music]
a loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you
update update so shout out to the lord
jason rooney
but uh my man's you know i'm saying run
a little bit late so um he will be
joining us in progress most likely but
uh we gotta actually go wait for it
we're gonna wait for the legend so um
he's still coming everything's a go so
real quick let me read some super chats
before i saw get here oh shout out to
master clowns shout out twenty dollar
super chat leave a comment brother
morales through the ceiling okay okay
and then um hold on general mac two
dollar super chat all hail the iop
salute the lord so yeah the legend is
still coming jason reuben i got off the
phone we good you know i'm saying just
need a little time so we might start
maybe maybe like five ten minutes after
but i'll keep you guys posted waiting
for the rest of the lawyers to get here
anyway so we good but we're gonna have a
good show
[Music]
[Music]
we got to give the legend his his proper
intro his flowers though we gotta give
his flowers so we will be back we will
wait hollow i see what's going on i'll
talk to you out of it
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
it i'm embarrassed for you i've always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you just a target when i'm
in the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on aim
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social love my city but i'm
still by coastal i
[Music]
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got this
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
the uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
and we are live
iron lord podcast
lord cognito here talking about the
latest with advanced gg there's a lot of
things going on with the new product
line let's get right to it
so we got that focus line y'all this is
that standard this is what we use right
now kind of our caffeine substitute and
what we usually do right now when we're
gaming we don't use coffee anymore we're
utilizing its focus on debt number two
you already know it's my favorite right
here the energy line you already know
birthday cake one of my absolute
favorites completely delicious this is a
pre-workout equivalent and also doesn't
use beta adeline so you don't get the
jitters and stuff like that so it's
really good for that and then the new
new we got that hydration line y'all
this is really good for people who don't
like caffeine who want an electrolyte
substitute and it is really sugar-free
absolutely delicious so you got your
three choices once again you know car
glove is sour you already know and we're
doing this right now so go get yourself
to
advancedgg.com use code iron lord on the
checkout this is something i use all the
time got to support advanced gg great
products if you want to get your workout
on even if you don't work out you're
just gaming you need that focus and
again the hydration line for those who
don't want caffeine no sugar
electrolytes you're good to go lower
cognito here iron law podcast
peace
[Music]
oh
[Music]
which flies
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young woofer
then they would mistake me for addict if
i can imagine this cooler give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you gonna be single player
like siren you gonna get tossed in the
bushes by king david royalty not a
pretender detrimental to an elemental
what's the avatar to a knee bender i
gotta be me though i know it's my
destiny worth it who cares if you fly if
you steal a mosquito
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen
[Music]
all right a little little mic check so i
can see a level a level there hello sir
yeah there you go there you go now we
looking good
all right hear ye hear ye and we are
live welcome to the iron launch podcast
llc and also live on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 267 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date and today i'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got metaverse content
and the co-founder of naughty dog
is saudi scared of xbox owning call of
duty
deus ex return and a series that's sdk
to discuss so we're gonna get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who not only
began his journey as a young savant
within video game development but whose
illustrious career is highly revered as
a visionary to iconic franchises and the
virtual universes he now empowers our
developers to create
introducing
the vp of metaverse contech at meta
co-founder of naughty dog and creator of
the crash bandicoot plus jack and daxter
franchises the iron saint of comics who
moves in mysterious ways but will always
give the realest speech at any developer
conference
live from cali don't shake your head we
loved it kind enough to make his debut
at the realm of the lord
my man lord jason reuben how we doing
sir you embarrass me
that's too much but i do know what it
took until episode 267 to get me on so i
know at least
266 that were even better introductions
before this right is that the way it
works but i'm glad to be here absolute
pleasure to have you in the role man a
legend of the game
i know you got so much going on have you
got a chance to be playing any games
during all this visionary all this
creation and stuff you've been doing
you know it it's getting harder as i get
older i mean i used to be the gamer if i
wasn't doing something that i had to do
i was playing games but then i
you know you're working hard yeah in the
crash series at naughty dog i was
playing games because i needed to look
at the competition at this point with
two kids a wife working at meta i you
know
i don't get to play a lot when i do play
my daughter wants me to play roblox or
wonderbox or you know
gentian impact or something i i don't
get a lot of time for my own gaming so i
have
not as much as i'd like i hate yeah it
was at least at least you still getting
it shout out to the daughter still doing
it up and i play the vr titles you know
i do i do try to keep up with that and
make sure i see what's in the store and
everything but quite often i'm playing
this stuff that isn't out yet which i
can't talk about today yeah that's right
that's right
what'd you say
no i said that that's that's a great
thing um i i can sympathize with that
yes yes
and you already know we got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the realm here at the round table
with time-sensitive intros so we want to
respect lord jason why do you have to
always remind after respect lord jason's
time lord king who eats other people's
minutes but anyway if they hand them to
me
[Laughter]
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man lord addict how are we doing sir
doing pretty good you know what i love
what you love about me i love how king's
acting like if we didn't if we took up
all of our time if we sat here and did
all the time we was allocated and he
acted like he wouldn't still do that um
all day to be listening to you he was
time on me so he could steal my time
he's a thief
so quickly sir what you've been playing
uh i've been playing a game called uh
sympathy of war
there will be a review why people always
say addicts levels are low yeah it
sounds like your mic source is actually
changed it does sound like it's coming
from a different bike source for
whatever reason but it's all good you're
still still fine i just you can tell
it's different
yeah
yeah look at you was attacking the chat
now
excuse me answering me wait a second
don't worry it's totally professional
lord jason you see it's a professional
sometimes i have to keep this chat on
online wow you sound magnificent
addict's world y'all but so symphony of
war that's that's been interesting award
yes and there will uh my review is done
and after the podcast uh we'll be
premiering into it no doubt hope you
guys enjoyed it was actually a really
fun time you know what's funny i was
doing research on it when i was doing
the review and uh only two people made
that game it's crazy
it's so crazy
funny you said to me like what i'm
talking about when i play it it's so
interesting you said that oh shout out
to one away dragon tv in the building
good to see you brother successor on
your surgery
good to see you man i i just noticed
that i wanted to give one man limpy
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also testosterone
lord
lord clarity and patreon making me laugh
lord clarity yeah your lord clarity now
of the i am fake mommy lord sovereign
how are we doing sir i'm good doing
fantastic man doing fantastic um
let me see let me see what i've been up
to this week oh
you know papa gabe copper game giveth
you know i still rocking with the steam
deck so the thing is
i haven't been a tweaker for a long time
you know i i fell into the console stuff
and i kind of strayed away from my roots
tweaking pcs and messing with stuff but
the steam deck has just brought me back
you know like like michael corleone and
brent brought me back in and
so i'm messing with that and and what i
forgot that the steam deck had at my
disposal that i just completely forgot
about
fsr 2.0
oh
messing around with the settings trying
to get things so that it's it's looking
good
running well but there was still little
hiccups here and there so i'm like wait
a minute
fsr
so i didn't really i didn't know how to
access it on on the uh on the steam deck
so i you know googled found some stuff
out
threw that on
different speaker difference because
honestly like you could run that
at like 720p even less than that you can
run it at 720p with
basically most effects on looking
beautiful whatever and then the
upscaling episode fsr makes it look
native you know whatever the screen is
720p native 800p native
so it just brings it up and it looks
super crisp and yet you don't lose any
of the performance
it is so beautiful that you got to work
the place
congratulations i thought i didn't like
this combat talk
now you don't you don't like steve talk
about that
listen listen you peons
he's back to race now yeah exactly
exactly he said that he said he called
us peony
all i know back in the day king would
buy this just to buy it even if it was
going to collect dust
i just don't understand a guy that you
would have to put like a chair together
to play a game like that's ridiculous
excuse me these are not expedited intros
continue but jason has clearly uh
pointed out i have grown up sir and i'm
yeah
and i don't have time to be tweaking my
game you have grown up with all your
tattoos in the background yes you've
grown up he's grown up continue i love
you
um yeah so that was it that's okay
that's been fun because a lot of stuff
that doesn't seem to run super great
and
and the main thing about it is that i'm
fiddling with pcs again which i have not
done in a long time so that's fun
absolute salute and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka the
access gamer oh
the prophet of xbox i mean king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
beloved lord king how you doing sir lord
jason's going to get something oh
and you know something hold on
i got to say hold on i'm so happy that
you ran and got jack and dexter look at
that
awesome freaking love them love that i'm
so happy that you even just reached back
see that that's how god works people
yeah god works beautifully very well
um
this whole week i was gonna do combat
talk last night and i didn't do it
because it was a zone show and i'm not
into bum bashing right uh what they do
is they set up uh
at the a side of the card to be somebody
that is supposed to be dominated i don't
think that's how sports is supposed to
go
i think it's supposed to be fair
competition every time you step inside
the ring and i wasn't going to waste
your time my time and anybody else's
time on a card that wasn't working all
the time so they're on that tomato can
pay-per-view
oh no
okay
i mean listen
i don't mind i don't mind tomato cans if
they're on espn
when you make me pay for that but if i
got to pay for it
tomato can i
finish
uh
jedi fallen order oh okay shout out to
responses
yeah because i since i heard about the
black panther
i wanted to go back and i wanted to
evaluate the team okay um
and i think it won't be a fair
assessment because of the fact that it's
a last generation game yeah so my
nitpicks with the game is based on the
fact that the limitations of the last
generation hardware doesn't translate to
current generation hardware and i see
certain things that they can improve on
but as i was talking with attic this
week because he was like oh you you
almost finished with it because i told
him where i was at and you didn't call
me when you finished it oh no i didn't
because it was it was uh 4 30 in the
morning sir
i saw you i saw you
you jumped on um but it's such a great
surprise for a certain character that
does show up and he's a very iconic
character inside uh star wars uh
franchises and the way that displayed
him
they have the reverence of this
character so
the story
some of the cinematics
in this game is top-notch and you really
feel like you're part of the law of the
star wars so
if if if they can capture the essence of
the black panther and bring the essence
of the black panther over there he's
coming around all right no because i i i
i
unjustly uh yeah she was very harsh and
very harsh last week
but but that was off of initial i feel
like
and off off of past reputation so i
don't trust ea in that space especially
with a character like the black panther
that i yeah so remember remember it's
not it's not respond making it yeah but
you assume that the influences of right
you know they've been done with thank
you for the software yeah so um that's
all i've been doing um and i've been
playing fortnite so fortnite uh
has a skin in there
that's part of the jedi fall in order
last villain that i'm trying to get and
shout out to young chris uh we were
playing and we got our
chicken dinner uh because he wanted to
be lebron james all the time
no doubt hey i'm sorry just real quick i
think what king uh you know what i sense
what king was saying is now since he's
played father order and he saw that they
did respect that lore and they brought
it to that game in such a great way that
he can
maybe
have a little bit more hope that they
would do that okay
[Music]
no doubt and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself the shinobi lord
cognito spreading that relish in the
realm of iop not tell you what you want
to hear but what you need to hear shout
out to defining duke my boy mr maddie
plays had a good one talking about call
of duty stuff that we were going to talk
about later also on the patreon lsn
patreon we have the uh friday duke
ultimate exclusive as does falls shout
out to interior knight the uh little
indie studio out there in london we do a
spoiler cast we talk about the choices
and all that stuff shout out to ben
smith who came through fun game i highly
recommend you guys give it a shot uh we
did last word would he bounce so i got
travis have her man stadia time which is
hilarious a stadium created and dude was
a banana he was yeah
and when i saw that i said i don't know
how you kept it together i don't know
how he literally did the whole show
through obs as a banana he's super
talented um as far as me on naraka
bladepoint i've been playing the uh the
campaign came out very cool little dark
souls s3 playing co-op and then um vr i
got a shout out purple yonder games uh
lord jason um they have a title it's
called little cities and i'm like such a
sim cities guy so i'm like
yeah it's like you giving me siv city
and then they got the touch controls now
so i put the august controllers down and
i'm sitting there manipulating the boy
it's so relaxed it's like so it's like
your city too like you feel like you're
the god looking over it right
the screen and the window that you used
to have
absolutely man i've been playing that
obviously still dbo of course a huge dbo
fan shout out to the uh the necromancer
class but yeah i wanted to give purple
y'all they love i really it's a relaxing
game and it's just it's my power wash
simulator for vr like i just relax i'm
sitting there making my cities do about
seeing what the demands are and all that
other stuff so start off real quick so
we get into all before we get into lord
jason let's um set the uh rules of
engagement with the students yeah guys
so uh we only have jason for a limited
amount of time well
maybe a little longer than than i guess
but but again we still got to respect
this time so uh
any question
nice
you know so what we're gonna do is kind
of wait there'll be specific times maybe
later on and we'll have some the super
chats to be able to to read off some of
them but any channels that come in since
yeah any super chats that come in early
on we're just gonna hold off till later
so
but again ask everything that you want
but uh just understand that yeah you
gotta get through the interview exactly
thank you guys also so we caught up with
super chats right we good no we got to
read two super chats we got
god's hitman
[Laughter]
please like and share this podcast
appreciate you brother appreciate
appreciate you really
there we got gerald mack five dollar
super chat looking forward to hooking up
with k asante on contractors today ilp
should join us
yo shout out to case out he does a good
podcast definitely we're going to link
up what it do to podcast review i
believe shout out to ksi very
nice sir what else we got and we got uh
lord metroid member for 11 months proud
to be a member of this community and the
best podcast in the universe i even get
out here on planet thieves hey jason
muchisimas gracias
shout out to him and we're good all
right cool let's get these topics going
so yeah that we've done our super long
intros
we did all right we did all right
his video game system history his
journey into game development co-founded
the iconic naughty dog studio and of
course what led him to oculus and
becoming the vp of metaverse content so
lord jason let's start from the very
beginning what are some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you with the gaming
yeah very beginning channel f was the
first video game system i own it wasn't
the first video game i played but that
was the first video game system i own
and for those that don't know that was
before atari that was the first
cartridge-based system
it was
brilliant but then nothing came out for
for a while and so i had all you know
this is pong
[ __ ] breakout i mean the graphics
were horrible
the controllers were miserable yes it
was beautiful i was on it all day and it
was the closest thing you could have to
arcade at home yeah uh i missed atari i
had a sega system i had nintendo systems
and then you know playstation and
everything came out
but uh
yeah i mean you want me to talk about
how i got into games yeah i'll be before
i want you to back up a second just a
second cause we can be a kid we got we
got to get up on some questions here um
yeah i've never heard a channel wait
wait you never you guys have never
played a fair child no okay let me let
me explain something to you thank god
someone came on the show and said
this is just for men
my earliest console was the actual pong
console right the two paddles blah blah
blah
i didn't hear of a fear child
at all but i did have breakout in all
those other games i think the pong one
was earlier but it didn't have
cartridges so you bought it with the
games you played what was on it you know
game one game two game three you're done
that's it nothing new comes because they
didn't have any kind of removable system
right nlf the revolution was the
cartridge and that was what became
nintendo and everything else atari
everything came from that i'm looking at
pictures of it right now it looks like a
like one of those old cassette players
that cops would like record pretty much
what it was
yeah yeah this is awesome that's the
game you've ever heard look up jerry
jerry lawson creators of the video game
industry and didn't get a lot of
notoriety yes yes not at all
yep that guy deserved it absolutely
my grandfather won the channel f my
parents would never have gotten me a
video game system my grandfather won it
by getting closest to the hole in some
golf tournament he was a golfer and he
was like what the hell is that he gave
it to me and the next thing on the next
hole was a cadillac so he was like wow
wow wrong hole and i that career
that one thing
that one
shot on the golf you know off the tee
that was what created my career changed
my change my life so that was the
general app
did you get a chance well
did grandpa get a chance to see your
career
uh he saw some of the early stuff my
grandfather passed away when i was 17.
but by 17 i was working with ea as a
contractor so
it's not like he didn't see me make
video games but he saw the early stuff
he never saw crash bandicoot you know
naughty dog existed but he you know
you know
kids
as he saw his influence and what he did
in the younger days get you yeah
i still think he wanted the
he's cadillac there probably like you
know he's seeing you doing stuff and
he's like you know he's like this is
nice but that was a cadillac it wasn't
yet
so
old man in that time a cadillac was like
the thing yeah
that's what i was about to say i said
back then
man listen man
my fair child story i didn't own the
fair child but my grandparents didn't
they lived in brooklyn and we always
tried to visit them at least like twice
we visit them from the bronx like twice
a month right and i'd walk in and be
like hey you know give my grandparents a
kiss and then run right for the
fairchild right
when they passed away and they moved and
we at what they passed away and my my
grandfather passed away and my
step-grandmother moved back to puerto
rico
we went to help clean out the house
right and they had a whole bunch of
stuff
and by that time i was older i wasn't
interested in that so my dumbass did it
take the fair child with me like this
piece of history i'm like whatever you
know back then you just like very
flippant about what these things mean
after you moved on to the next thing and
i just like now that you mentioned base
mentioned that jason it's like oh god i
i literally threw the fair child in the
trash wow long gone too but that's what
makes things worth a lot more in the
future right i mean it doesn't pay
attention to it exactly you got a lot of
people that you know you know
it's funny that you know i've went
through and i've played all these old
pokemon games and then you go and you
look on amazon like that
that that's worth nine hundred dollars
like
i had that when i was 12. what happened
to it it's absolutely real it's it's
interesting to hear these stories of
inspiration and the first castle so you
went from that now you go through
you know obviously did you do the 2600
did you do the colecos
no so no atari like i just want to get
that transition to the next kind of
consoles right so the the way it worked
was i was into video games but i was
really into star wars like that's the
first thing that hit me in 1977 i
thought in the theater and i came out
and all my friends were whacking each
other at school thinking they were like
luke and i was like i want to be you
know
i want to be lucas i want to make stuff
and so i asked my father for a movie
camera because did he you know he didn't
have vhs and stuff like that he couldn't
get those cameras back then
and he said no way like
in florida over the shoulder
yeah exactly it was these things you
didn't have like your iphone to throw in
somebody's face everything was like
expensive and
you know ungainly and he was like
there's no way you're seven years old
and i kept begging for it
until someone put a computer in front of
me and that was in uh elementary school
wow
and so they put that in front of me and
i was playing already channel f and i
was like this is it this is my chance to
make worlds so i started asking for a
computer and i finally got one when i
was 13. my father thought it would be
the dumbest thing he ever did
because they're expensive like you know
four thousand dollars in you know this
was 83 yeah so this was a good
percentage of his salary he bought this
computer he's like i'm going to bounce
my checkbooks you're going to do your
homework most of that didn't happen but
i started making games immediately
i'm making worlds and so we were mostly
like apple ii apple 2gs yes
amiga atari st not the console stuff we
went the pc
okay so when you got to the amiga
because um i know apple uh did do a lot
of good stuff in the beginning because i
think my first uh pc slash gaming
console was the amiga but mine was the
amiga 64. right so i was a little bit
further on than that because i was in
the console realm
but um in the amiga uh
because the games were a little bit
different right uh
how did you experience those games but
you were making games at this period of
time right so yeah i was making crappy
games i mean let's be clear the first
step i made was you know i was 15 when i
published my first game it was called
skeet grades you can look it up you're
crazy one one thing that i i do want to
point out she had 15. yeah yeah he uses
the for real public
my son is 11 and you know they have him
in programming he's got four years tell
him yeah
i'm going to tell him you got to publish
you got to publish
my daughter is 17 she published her
first book at 16. but
you missed it by a year don't count yeah
no it don't but it counts that's awesome
but
you publishing a game at 15 years old
that's a big thing at the table that's
how it is especially because the
industry was tiny right so
competitive packaging at that point the
first thing we did is we shoved discs
and ziplocks and took them to local
stores i'm i'm not counting that right
and people would be like am i gonna buy
this crappy game in a ziploc bag that
was competitive like a lot of people had
that this is like nobody used computers
back then it was total nerd territory
yeah and uh we used a tool kit from a
company called bodville
a spray
engine and so we had to send the next
game we made to them for approval to
publish it and they saw it and they said
let us publish it and that's how it
became
wow the true nationally published you
know in a box
real
game developer at 15.
at 15 years old please listen to my demo
hey and somebody hurt oh i was totally
he'd listen to my demo face totally
that's exactly what it was
good
one thing that you know
can already attest to like your artistic
mind is like you watching
star wars at a young age and instead of
wanting to be like luke like all your
friends like
you want to make the star wars you don't
want to be in the star wars yeah yeah i
think that's true of a lot of gamers and
a lot of like i have i live in l.a i'm
in l.a right now and i have friends that
are directors and the same thing is true
of them like they watch movies it's it's
entertaining but it for the most part
they're like hmm i didn't like the angle
of that show
just from the beginning it's about this
the tech and the story and the the
process for them um amazing yeah that
was just that was just who i am i wanted
to make my own stuff yeah it's an
amazing different mindset and at that
age and
at this time i'm gonna assume lord andy
this is when you guys link or this was
even even before that so i'm just
curious about when when andy comes into
and and we start to think about okay
you're doing the publishing game at like
forming a studio
yeah
it was it was actually pretty simple
i went to hebrew school
i didn't give a damn about hebrew school
there was this other kid that also had a
computer same type
i'm not going to say it you didn't give
a damn either yes yes two of us sat in
the back of hebrew school and did what
we wanted to do which is talk about
video games guys
i made this game called ski crazed
and as you went down the hill it got
slower because i was really bad at
programming but it looked for the time
okay
and he cleaned that up
and that was the game that vaudeville
published and then vaudeville said can
you do another one and i said i probably
can't program what you want and he
couldn't do the art the partnership
started
just like so i mean it was it was that
he was the person that helped me and i
was the person that helped him because i
was the artistic type and he was the
the coder type and it just it just
happened and you know like we were young
right so we didn't really even think
about it but then you have to
incorporate so you need a name and there
was this guy named mike
mike bought our first piece of software
so mike was part of the company that's
all he had to do
what was the name of the company
remember we were 14 13 years old we
weren't that creative so so mike bought
the piece of nowhere but mike couldn't
do anything after that
we needed to buy mike out of the company
right into the company dynamics at the
beginning and then it became jason and
andy's magic which is even worse
when ea finally said we'd like to work
with you and that was the third game we
published was with electronic art
artists it was called at that time right
um
uh
when we started working with them they
looked up jam software they found there
was actually a jam software in australia
and they said you can't use this name
because you know and so you need a new
name and you have 24 hours because we
got to sign the deal we're signing and
andy and i were like we we like dogs
naughty dog and that became the name oh
my god that's crazy
tripp hawkins who founded electronic
arts oh we have stories about
trips he was like
that is a horrible name
no no no no no look how it works you see
electronic artists micro pros interplay
that was exciting how it works you take
two tech names throw it together
that's your name
division and i was like
naughty dog and he's like oh man
tripp wasn't feeling it tripp was him
god you didn't listen i mean you know we
listened to trip we listened to triple
yeah oh yeah no he's a very smart man
but he was wrong about the name yeah
yeah he definitely was thank god
what's crazy is ea
pretty much influenced the name being
changed abnormalities they didn't change
like you guys doing it they're like look
this is a trademark you got to change it
because if they if there wasn't someone
yeah we'd have been jammed
it would it
never would have been naughty dog so it
would have happened anyway because we
couldn't get bigger without you know
really trademarking so we would have
found out the thing is they gave us 24
hours and had we had more time and done
it later the name probably wouldn't have
been as good
it was the flash that you know it was
naughty it was the perfect storm it was
the time clock over your head and he was
like hey we bad and we like dogs yeah i
remember i remember the logo like it was
very aggressive it was cool
it was it was the it had a little shades
king and stuff like it was cool yeah
exactly so the early logos were pretty
cheesy but
remember it's 80s
they were totally
straight up right in the center of
everything that was wasn't until later
we got the current logo it was where it
was supposed to be actually
in in that period of time but we were
always circling the same universe you on
the side of creation us on the side of
the consumer and we were with you in
this journey not knowing that this
journey will lead to this moment
the earlier you were a video game player
the more you were part of the success of
this business there is there is no
question because no one respected the
industry at all so people that believe
that these were real pieces of
entertainment they were art they were
worthwhile as opposed to the
conventional wisdom back then which was
games is toys right
for kids that's why it's sold and toys r
us
right all of these things if you look
back absolutely took
people who really believed and as they
got older not giving up
on games taking them with them so that
now people my age and below we're still
playing games and it's no there's no
question it is an art form it is
entertainment writ large it's as big as
anything yeah absolutely and that's a
fantastic point jason because people
have to remember like these infancy
stages it was kind of i could only
imagine what you may have went through
maybe from your parents or your family
because it wasn't considered a career it
was considered at all yeah like
something okay you this is some hobby
you're doing but why don't you go to
school and get a real profession what
are you going to be like you're going to
look at your 100 percent yeah
i hit it for my high school friends
i wouldn't have talked about making
video games i was making money
crazy and i was hiding the fact that i
was making money doing this because i
didn't want to be a nerd i just didn't
want to i was a nerd but i didn't want
people to like oh not on top of the fact
that you look like a nerd i didn't look
like you look like
um did you go to the arcades because
arcades was big in our age all right so
you freak him into arcade um
they didn't question how much money you
had
yo
pocket watching are you pocket watching
the young jason you're in the arcade
spending then you have some money on you
that i mean
he's the dude walking with a pocket full
of quarters he's going up to the machine
and he's put you remember how he used to
put our money in water's coming up yeah
so you that guy and you know and you
uh andy and
well he's he's gone
now yeah i don't know where mike is now
no totally
mike's looking at everything and
regretting selling his piece off
but mike had birds in the arcade too
though like before i made well actually
yeah right before i made ski crazed
right we decided that we were going to
make super punch-out which at the time
was one of the biggest huge like it was
insane yeah and so we went to the arcade
and put you know
tons of quarters on the thing i sat with
a camera and we took pictures of super
punch out so i could come home count
pixels wow
and put that into the spray and we had
it running
my father is a lawyer and he looked at
it and he's like you're going to jail
you can't do this
i mean it's fine for you to do this at
home but like you can't sell this and i
was like no i'm going to get nintendo to
let me put it out on my computer
this is classic you know i'll let her
know
no you can't do this
shout out to his mind for him and his
little cohort to go in there and to take
pictures and reverse engineer a puncher
punch out
you know
64k
that's what we had
right your facebook profile picture on
mobile many many times now
okay so like just your profile yes 64k
andy could fit in 2k
the code because i took the rest for the
art and somewhere along the line keep in
mind this kid's 14 wow somewhere in the
line oh also yes you save everything on
a disc no hard drives no hard drive yeah
that's a good point no backups if you
don't keep putting discs in so he keeps
writing over the same code and he got
himself into a place where we called it
the it bug he doesn't know what happened
the thing crashed
and he couldn't fix it
and that was the end of superpower
i could just like see the back of your
dad's mind because you said he didn't
approve of the gaming thing at first but
he's like you know maybe he should do
this you know maybe after he has a
little bit of legal issues he'll stop
this
yeah but at the same time like i was
going to be a lawyer so it was fine
having a hobby is a good thing my father
was incredibly supportive my parents
were incredibly supportive but at the
same time
i was going to be a lawyer
it was bad yeah right those two things
were weighing against each other he look
as a lawyer
we we brought out way of the warrior for
3-d hold on don't you go there don't you
go i got a whole segment away okay i got
a whole segment please hold that one
because i gotta ask you a question he
was on that journey with you we're
almost there we're almost there because
we were that's when we
really
fell in love with naughty dog and jason
everybody else fell in love with naughty
dog exactly we knew about this game but
we're gonna get today so really don't
listen to it jason i fell in love with
keith the thief that's what i was
thinking
so i just i just wanted a pixel on that
i drew
beautiful white stuff
before we get into where the warrior
took i do want to talk about like i said
so you go to trip you got you figure out
jam already has the you know the the
trademark thing you switch it's naughty
dog now electronic arts is their trip is
over there now is this you guys doing pc
games but this when did the genesis
thing come into the play so we we we did
keep the thief which was you know
pc right personal computer not it was on
pc but it was also an amigo target
apple that whole sequence uh because
things were kind of spreading out there
there were a lot of there were a lot of
different types of desktop computers
and uh and and you know they wanted us
to do another game and it was it was
pretty clear we weren't going to do
adventure games like keith thief so we
started working on
an rpg
um
you know that was rings of power
and it was it was also going to be on
desktop computers like that we started
on exactly the same computers we were
working on and
we had some meeting i don't remember
what it was but it was only andy and he
flew to uh and he flew to ea okay and he
was at ea and i came up the next day i
think it was the next day uh to meet him
and uh and he was like we're making a
console game and i'm like why he's like
see that that's a reverse engineered
genesis
ea is gonna put out genesis games
they're not gonna pay sega whoa remember
that and he saw that and apparently he
[Music]
yeah you're reverse engineering and
genesis because you could see what it
was and they're like sign this science
you decided
so you got when you were andy bumped
into that wasn't supposed to see that
like i think we should probably make a
genesis game and they're like whatever
you want man just send an excuse
whatever you want
the struggle went down i love this
this is great that's the wild west man
that's when you could just
remember when they came out with their
cartridges people have to buy their
cartridges from uh sega right yeah if
that's how it went
from my belief uh and ea came out with
their cartridges and they had the yellow
the yellow tab on the side yes
remember uh because nintendo had a
strong hold on uh the cartridge
situation with them with the licenses
and stuff like that this is how they
made their money
so ea said
i know that's so cool is a smart man
like i said
ship is a trip man
when it comes to the like cartridges
like i can't
uh you know i'm definitely the youngest
one here like i missed that on a lot of
that i caught a little bit but like
obviously i played like nes and stuff
growing up but i didn't own one uh so
like the majority of like my experience
with cartridges is like
pretty much like the end of the super
nintendo on like the n64 like and then
pretty much after that you know
obviously they stopped doing them but
yeah well cartridges cartridges were
good for a couple of reasons like
obviously they had a game on them and i
said you know early titles
they were really really expensive
rings of power sold out when it came out
in like two weeks wow
getting more of them
like they could only get so many
cartridges from sega and they were like
we're gonna go with this other game that
just as well as you we think it has more
long-term potential as a series and
we're like what wait like what sold
like you're not going to make money he's
like no no no no we're going to make
this madden game that came out at the
same time
it seems to be doing well we think it's
going to be a series for us
football come on this rpg
so the cartridge itself like just the
physical goods yeah was 14 15 on our on
our thing not sega wasn't making a
profit on that that's just what it costs
together and that that wasn't good for
the industry because you know consumer
doesn't get any value out of that other
than it works we had to pay you know
came out of our money came out ea's
money came out so when cd came out
mm-hmm that's why andy and i here we go
and 3d 3d was before it looks good
cheap
is that
just real quick is that like when you
hear a lot of like stories on you know
companies really pushing to get out of
the cartridges like for instance like
when square enix like really pushed for
nintendo to get out of it and they
didn't what that was one of the key
reasons because they knew it wasn't good
for the industry and they were trying to
get as many people to do it as possible
everybody just want you get more memory
you know cartridges are expensive you
want a lot of memory on a cartridge
because
all developers need more space
we had a battery backup because you have
a you know it was a 400 hour game
roughly speaking for you know the few
people that finished rings of power like
you had to have a save game and the only
way to do a save game back then was to
put a battery in a chimney
battery and so you know that's a buck a
buck 50 for every game that didn't have
it save yep
was a cheaper cartridge we had more
memory because they were a smaller game
like so they just wear a cheaper
cartridge so when they were looking at
it even if we sold the same number of
units
man was the better thing to print yeah
from a business standpoint i made so
many games so we got it
yeah no it's it's okay i can't get out i
gotta come out no i mean um because i'm
you're getting we're we're now we have
to move a little bit faster right
because we get into the part where
uh the industry is being held back by a
couple of companies that are actually
making money off of this uh
cartridge-based system and the fact that
it's fast
but then cds came out
my early my earliest cd based uh system
for the house
was a one-speed drive uh turbo graphics
second one was the neo geo one speed
drive very slow and that was the
deterrent but
then speed started catching up
and um the 3d oh let's we could let's go
about the difference but let's
concentrate on
and uh how did that that that that
unveiling to you guys go because y'all
you guys are
actually going to be the backbone for
this concept that they have to and they
will bring it to fruition because they
reverse engineered genesis so
this is going to happen
right yeah trip wanted to build a
console and he wanted to change the
business right so he started working on
3do we didn't know about 3do
this whole we're not going to print any
more
rings of powers like that's crazy you
sold out and then they telling you you
can't yeah i'm sorry that's right and
we're talking about like you know for
kids that at the time i was 21 22 years
old this was a lot of money for me like
it was the difference between you know
we did fine but like we would have been
wealthy very wealthy and so we were
pissed and so i decided i was going to
get in the special effects industry and
andy decided he was going to get a
phd in computer science from mit and so
we actually stopped making games for a
little while and i started doing special
effects and i had just gotten myself uh
the ability to do wolf
the movie wolf i don't know if you
remember that it was you you did that
no no i didn't but i like there was this
thing called a morph if you remember
back then right where the person's face
would turn into another person's yes
and all the morphs were really cheesy
they were like
aren't you talking to me
i did a moving morph which means the
person was turning and turning into
something else and in the case of wolf
they wanted the person to turn from a
human being into was jack nicholson jack
nicholson yeah that was one of my
favorite movies i'm a werewolf dude
right so i did a moving morph and the
way i did a movie morph is i took a pen
and i wrote on my monitor all the points
for every frame and it took me
absolutely forever like it was not a
computer doing it it was me doing it the
hard way but it was such a good demo
that i got the ability to do one scene
for the for wolf oh and i was about to
sign the contract when trip hawkins
reached out and said we need you guys
back we're like we're out of the
industry man you like the whole
cartridge thing he's like i'm not an ea
anymore i'm at 3do
it's a cd
[Music]
it's got all this memory and it's cheap
and we're like all right we're back in
so so so now you make the commute you
took the beat out like you just tripped
yourself water yeah
we we ready
he's amazing so now you go okay you get
to get the get the band back together
you now
fly out drive out and take this beat
like how does this meeting happen where
now we're talking about
we're going to make this game
and then there's the hardware we signed
the nda
he sent us the hardware andy and i
started messing with and we're like look
it's infinite memory it's like 600 mags
or something
panasonic interactive real
3d yes yeah right it's got all these
things
we're going to make a game and what
we're going to do is we're going to make
mortal kombat like we literally just
said we're going to make mortal kombat
now just like super punishment
is smarter
the king sees the trend king
we got smarter though so we're like it
can't actually be mortal kombat
you're not you're not gonna break the
camera it ain't fit
the problem with your father your father
was in your ear and he said hey now
if you're gonna do it let's go do this
go ahead so we we uh we we shot her i
went to boston because andy was still at
mit artificial you know
he was gonna he computer science he was
he was gonna get a phd at this time but
terminator yeah that didn't end up
working out we can get into that and so
we start making this game and we made it
basically in his dorm room and wow we
spent together and we put all of our
money that we and not the money we
didn't have from the damn rings of power
but all the money that we did have from
rings of power yeah put into making this
game i'm two of the characters kona tori
and the ninja got it
[Applause]
now i am no protecting order
one fight oh you was the way you was the
skull oh i was yes i was the skull i was
the voice i'm not doing a good job i
don't have a good mic
shaky jake this was this was like it was
basement computing it was just the two
of us all our money
making this thing
is it true
is it is it true that when you guys were
filming you guys i had to sort of like
open up your door and like there were
neighbors that thought you were you were
filming other types of things
was in mit so we were in like a dorm
yeah
and uh you know to get
i didn't know anything about cameras you
know we were shooting real people like
mortal kombat and then you know
rotoscoping around so we got rid of the
background we were to we didn't have a
green screen like my friend here
we didn't have the money so we just put
a sheet on the wall so we had a shoe
and i would do every pixel around the
edge and eventually we hired people to
do it but the way my camera lens worked
we needed to be pretty far from because
i only had one lens we'd be pretty far
from the from the person and that meant
out the front door in the hallway
so the door was always open when we were
shooting whoever it was that was doing
the stuff all dressed up in you know
wacky costumes at chinatown in boston
maximum 150 dollars that was our limit
that's the limit of the budget
the bonus character that's my pillowcase
with the corners cut off wow like a
diaper on it the cable from our you know
the window shades around his waist
they thought that their food was pouring
in here the lowest budget you could do
and of course people were like you know
screaming each other in the room and do
this do that and our neighbors yeah they
thought we were filming something as
well
resolution
your resolution on that game
to me looked higher yeah ridiculous
graphically
the 3d okay so the 3d we get it in the
house and i'm going to tell you from the
consumer standpoint all right because
all three of us have this uh
behemoth of uh it was about seven
hundred seven hundred dollars like seven
hundred we committed we committed it
yeah we definitely 100
and
you guys were the the killer app it was
you and and and and what was that battle
battle uh
the racing game they had crash crasher
bird was the launch trash and burn burn
crashes
working with us on crash but we didn't
know him at the time so
what happened with 3do
is it was a cd so all these people
thought we would get what they called
multimedia or mixed media so people
started doing all of this stuff that
kind of was a game but it kind of wasn't
a game full motion video craze yes and
it all sucked and no one really wanted
it and we were like you know mortal
combat we were gonna do something that
that worked um
that's right and so when we showed up at
the trade show on our own dime spent
like ten thousand dollars to get like a
three foot by three foot booth we had no
publisher and everyone was like
that's going to work it's a game
everything else that we're building is
like this experience
yeah and it it came and it went and
there were just a few games that were
game games
and so there was a bidding war for us
basically publishers to bring it out and
you know 3do was one of the bidders and
saying no to trip was one of the hardest
things we ever did
the man
when you speak to him i don't know if
you've ever done it
i did he
but we had he wanted to talk to us one
last time and we owed it to him to talk
to him one last time and everything back
then was done in person so we flew out
and i remember i had a pencil in the
meeting i was in and i put it under the
desk into my leg and i pushed up against
the desk so there was a little pain
because i'm telling you that man had an
effect on you can you believe you like
don't believe me
to remind me of reality
and the fact that universal was probably
the better deal and andy and i walked
out of there the only time we probably
ever said no to trip wow and sign went
universal they brought it out and then
they said what are you doing next
all right so why before we go there this
is amazing
again the the reason about we love it
it's such a cult class i know people
like the clown it we loved it first of
all graphically for its time it was
amazing
first of all let's give me a fl yeah how
did y'all get that music did you have
like white
tracks like the soundtrack it was
amazing
that was that was universal we went to
universal and they're like you need some
music for this and you know
up until that point i had done the music
for most occasions
it was horrible
and they're like well it's a cd you can
put on real music now what would you
want and we were like
white zombies
just so happens
and sure enough we met rob zombie and
taught him around the back universal's
back lot and he's a great man
that moved that pencil yeah in that
meeting
yeah very important for us
because
when we got that game
i mean for our 700
right uh it was some stuff that was hit
or miss like you were saying people were
doing different things that weren't
actually really games but you know you
watching the controllers were terrible
oh yeah
shout out to
unscrew it just so you can do the
diagonals
unscrew the back of the controller a
little to loosen it up and then it works
and if you did that the game was okay if
you didn't do that the game was
unplayable yep you're right to mr high
we have uh
we had our engineer that reversed
right yeah so he showed us because we
was absolutely we really wanted to love
this game yes we were telling people
it's better than mortal kombat
because when we had our fatalities yeah
you know the pecking order i swear to
god i love this yes
so
uh mr ha shout out to
how bad we wanted to really play with
this game he knew the limitations was
the controller you know how some people
intuitive yeah you saw star wars and he
saw the controller as the limitation he
went and fixed it
called us on the phone and said give me
your controller yep went inside his
house
fixed it didn't tell us what the hell he
was doing
it said now play it
yeah his fix was a couple of turns of a
screwdriver yeah
that's where they got everything wrong
it was just too tight
by the way i have i have apologized for
boone for ripping off mortal kombat
don't don't apologize
was who he is and has taught me a lesson
since then and his response was we all
stand on the shoulders of giants like
and it is totally true
i grab from him he grabs from others we
all grab from each other the games today
some of the stuff came from my stuff
some came from other stuff we all
continue to build and you have to love
that so you can't go rip off super punch
out but so long as it's not a ripoff
you're fine question
why we didn't get part two
you didn't get part two because part one
and the 3do was like
yeah sales right the 3do didn't quite
make it and then everybody was like oh
this cd thing's gonna work right sega
was like this is it this is going to
work this is going to be our edge
against nintendo and sony who had been
building a cd-rom drive for let's go
look it up let's go yup that's the
history nintendo and sony didn't work
out this is all online you can go look
it up
let's go so let's transition down there
right there was an opportunity because
the thing about the 3do that we loved
was it wasn't a sega it wasn't a
nintendo so all the big publishers
they weren't looking at it right they
were looking at the things and so we had
a chance to make a mortal combat without
there being a mortal kombat competing
with us right so we saw sony come in we
two arrogant kids still two of us
should have been 1994-ish
let's go we were like we're just going
to make the mario for them
for saying yeah you got a mario for
nintendo oh that's good let's get it
listen sony's not gonna have one so
we're gonna do it let's get that
literally like these arrogance there
this is great
i love your brain
i love how they target the deficiencies
in what they don't have what the
companies they're about to work with
yes always do the thing that everyone
else isn't doing
like i always look at these teams that
are like we're gonna be call of duty and
i'm like no no no they know what they're
doing like
no
like do something different like if you
you know it's 100 people playing at once
yes that's new i like that like do
something different it's not that you
can't stand on the shoulder of giants
and don't take them on directly
it's a good point it's a good don't do
that right
to this crash
i'm right there let me get it
i got you i'm excited too he got me hi
you get a chance to talk to them all the
time
all right
you're right you're right
you are let me just set it up for you
let me say that
fundamentally
formulated
our whole aggressiveness because we're
going to get to the aggressive part of
crying
that's where i'm at right now that's why
don't go for that because i cannot wait
for this part it's funny because i see
it kicking making a fantastic point
because i see why we really gravitated
towards nobody dogs
to the labeling the branding so now we
get here and it's okay universe you get
the deal and we to me this is the magic
moment right because
now you know what jay said you guys
create this rambunctious
mascot well let's be honest can he
really set the tone for a new generation
this is a this is a sony right
like this is sony doing it in this
console's market they've been kind of
shunned by nintendo and it's like okay
we're gonna do this they don't have a
mascot here comes jason and here comes
this this beloved character and now
he what's funny is to me i was gonna
remember the marketing you know brash
outside the
he's told me that he reverse engineers
and y'all guys are great
who and you you are andy
who likes the tasmanian devil
it was both of us thank you
the reason crash became something so
first of all we're like driving cross
country from boston now to universal and
they say what are you doing next so we
haven't
quite settled on what we're doing and
we're talking you know we there was rpgs
because we always loved rpgs especially
andy like andy wanted to make world of
warcraft that's really the game they
wanted to make it hadn't existed yet
like i don't know where we would have
been or whether we could have made it
but i wanted to make something that
could come out more quickly
something that filled the gap right that
like we knew had we knew what to do we
knew the parameters we just had to solve
some hard problems and and done and so
we're talking we're like we come up with
this whole sega's got sonic nintendo's
got mario we're gonna do this thing and
then we're like
it's a problem here it's a 3d system
what does sonic and mario look like on a
3d system and now like you don't think
of this but at the time
everything was left and right scrolling
yep yeah
like that wasn't really what people
wanted we thought now
sega didn't use sonic
did go with side scrolling yes and came
up with knights and we believe the
reason they came up with knights is that
they didn't want to risk sonic on it
because they didn't know if it was going
to work
and that that didn't satisfy people they
didn't want side scrolling in 3d
mario which we didn't know at the time
had been started but you know it's
obviously gonna bring out mario miyamoto
said it's a 3d system we're going to
totally rewrite things and it's going to
be open world right which i think in the
long run was actually the right way to
go the challenge that they had was the
systems were really weak so you couldn't
do that much visually with that right
because you just didn't have the
polygons not that it wasn't a fantastic
game when it came out but it didn't look
the same as the games you were used to
which had a lot of detail and things it
was pretty pretty blank yeah so what we
decided to do is take the side scrolling
and just turn it 90 degrees and
basically you're going in and out
instead of going left and right and you
have a little bit of movement to the
left and the right you can go around
things but really it's all on a path yes
so we we and would this work
we didn't know and it took a year to get
it to work and feel right and people
were saying at the time
you know
character action platformers they're not
gonna work in 3d it's not going to be
good like how do you time your jump you
can see exactly how big the jump is like
there were all these
it took a long time so that's what we
did and we kept the side scrolling on
some of the levels yes and then we were
like if you can go into the screen we
some of them go up and down some of them
go left and right we're doing everything
we're trying to can you go into the
screen
that was the boulder quick question
before i get to attic do you think cause
now that i look back at crash
historically yes it was 3d but you're
right there was a hybrid in a sense
because you still had the two you know
the 2d levels and things like that so do
you think it was more okay let's play it
safe
in case it's not fully adopted 3d all in
was not fully adopted was that the
balance what we said is if you go 2d
side scrolling you can get high
resolution graphics but it doesn't feel
like you should be doing that on a 3d
system right you go completely open
world you have to reduce your polygon
counts to the point where it just
doesn't look that interesting right and
again i'm not disparaging you know mario
64. it was amazing but we just didn't
want that look we wanted to stay without
yes and so by doing what we did
we created a paradigm in which it both
felt like a new type of gaming going in
and out of the screen but it also had
the incredible detail that crash had yes
and
then there was i mean you could go
online you can look there is like one
convention
one ces where all of a sudden all three
of these things no one knew about anyone
else they show up sony uh it's it's so
complicated like we started working on
this for universal but we signed the
contract with sony and they signed very
few developer contracts they always
signed contracts and the publisher
contract said we get to approve anything
before you start it okay right developer
contract they just sent you the hardware
and they didn't care because you can't
publish it without a publisher right we
took advantage of that to build crash
without even sony knowing oh they don't
even know
okay and then we show it to sony
and then we finally show it to sony
and they see this and they're like
we need a mascot yeah
not a mascot that we're gonna call the
mascot but we need one of these games
and guess what we don't have one
like
exactly what we said would happen
like anyone who is successful that tells
you that they're a genius and it's all
about the way they do business is is a
lie good point you need luck this is the
luck the luck was
nobody else had this thought
all of a sudden you got crash they know
mario's coming
here we are now here's the thing and so
sony's like we need this and universal
and sony went back and forth and there's
all this stuff but long story short we
show up at the convention and there's a
there's photos online a miyamoto playing
crash i was just about to ask you and
he's like you can see in his eyes you
can't see it in the photos because
you're looking at the background
in his eyes he's like
this is actually going to be trouble
[Applause]
let's go
i'm pretty much and he is the man like
he's the legendary
mario was the game but he also
understands the business and he saw what
this looked like
and he was like yeah this is going to be
a problem yeah that's what i'm saying i
got you i just want to say this because
that that's a that has to be a powerful
feeling right at one point you're
sitting there you know you take this bet
there's no mascot you bet on yourself it
looks phenomenal for its time and then
the legendary
side is there he's playing it and you
could see the energy like okay didn't he
ask them about the water
any questions did he have did he have
any questions or did he just kind of did
he kind of look and say okay
and then walk off
naughty dog is responsible for the core
of crash but there are a lot of people
that we're working on with us that
deserve credit for example uh you know
charles zumbalis and joe pearson did a
lot of the early design in 2d that
became crash and background and look
they were cartoon
designers they're brilliant you have
musicians that were doing uh music uh
mark mutato music muta josh mancell
you've got like you know sound effects
people at universal doing their work and
mark cerney
was the real addition to the actual
building of the game and the code
because he had worked on sonic so he had
a lot of ties yes so the other thing
about mark cerny is mark cerny speaks
japanese yeah and so had there been a
question it would have been in japanese
and it would have been directly to mark
probably and i don't remember if there
were any questions what i do remember is
that that very same convention there
were still doubts that crash should be
the mascot really and uh ken kudaragi
who was kind of the father of the legend
ken kudoran continue father playstation
he calls a meeting
and i wasn't in the meeting because
again it was in japanese so mark was in
there but my understanding and if you
ever interview mark you can find out
this is true is that he basically was
like completely livid that like well we
knew that they there was doubts that
americans
non-japanese people could make a game
that would seem like japan
no one really had but on top of that the
attitude all the things you can get into
why there was the attitude it just
didn't work for a lot of you know from
their perspective
is like what you should do is there
should be a music and the music should
link to the game
this is like
the thing about the thing about mario is
he's a very one-dimensional character
like right he's mario
and like there's not a lot of
personality there like try to think of
mario doing shakespeare
right exactly let's go it's not gonna
happen sonic is a two-dimensional
character he's fast and he kind of like
but he's not gonna do shakespeare either
right crash
you can see him doing like he has
attitudes he has emotions he's happy
he's sad he's and then by the time we
got to jack that was a three-dimensional
character jack and daxter
you have to have emotion and he has to
have an attitude and it was it was it
was that dis desire that made crash who
crash was it was it was american and we
had to clean that up for japan so if you
go look at the japanese marketing yes
completely different completely so
the reason i'll go ahead and go ahead
and add a picture
what's crazy is like you're going
against the grain of people who don't
think that crash should be a mascot for
a company like playstation and not to
mention you go to gets a grain of you
know people
say yo you're trying to go against mario
it's like you're not like deliberately
doing this like you you're sure we were
like that's what's going on in the
inside on the outside like i'm sure that
that's not the way you were marketing
stuff
because like to me it's like you know
you're gonna have outside people it's
like dude it's mario like how are you
going to compete with mario so let's see
but look what sony did like maybe blair
who was our marketing person like look
what happened the literally the ad they
went out with yeah
up to nintendo screaming we are here and
yes we are taking you on directly
call the plumbers come outside
what i'm referring to they failed before
that
to try to make a mascot and your guy
wasn't the guy it was jack flash
and it was apex skate
and he tried these two games
and those games didn't hit i mean ape
escape is like one of my favorite games
but those games didn't actually
gravitate to the face of the franchise
you guys
became the face of the franchise
and i know when they played it i don't
care what anybody says
when they actually played it
they said they hit it wait these guys
hit it the game was good like crash one
if you go back too hard you had some
it was rough it was wrong yeah it was a
tough game
like we hit our stride but yeah japanese
version of every game because i'm i'm
okay in this group i'm the test dummy
right so i'll run out and i'll buy the
japanese console and i'll i'll get these
games and i cause i want to play them
first i'm going to play them early and i
know it's a distinct difference in a lot
of stuff because there's a little
changes localization changes and stuff
like that
when i saw the commercial
this is a different sony at this point
in time remember this is a scoring sony
yes this is an upset very aggressive the
sony that is highly aggressive that's
why playstation was my favorite car so
they this was unheard it was like think
about it the time came that interrupts
you and i don't know we waiting to swim
too
it's the arrogance in a way but it was
this
brash we are here and at the time it was
unheard of to really challenge nintendo
like that nobody thought sony was going
to succeed right now
that's what i was bringing up it's like
look like that is a massive
even before that you know you brought
crash to sony and like that they
actually you know fully said oh you know
maybe this this could be a mascot like
the ideal that he's like i'ma take the
fight straight up to mario
the mindset back then is like that's
like equivalent to now it's saying yo
you know what i got the card killer yeah
on a platform that doesn't have call of
duty and that's
fill
if you're in a place they're not it's
taking them on in the place they are
just like yes that could not work
or better accurate one would be like you
know uh sony making like killzone and
stuff and saying you know quote-unquote
halo killer so i guess that that would
be more of an accurate you know what's
crazy too is like you don't i don't know
if you know this but for all you know
you know miyamoto is sitting there he's
playing crash and he's like you know
mario's good and mario's always going to
be around but we might need more mascots
because people are starting to come up
with more you know unique aspects to
these platforming area and you could
have
a domino effect that could have led to
another franchise that's being out right
now because of them playing that that's
what he did though
i just want i want to get one point over
crash on that before we move on because
the thing too is that you made a point
about two points you made a little jason
i thought a very insightful one in the
sense that we have to be honest even
though from an american standpoint we
love the aggressive nature we love that
i love when crash the character look
back at the screen to look at you right
from a 3d perspective and i think it was
the hog wild stage or whatever it was
really important we wanted to start with
this is a different character than
you're used to you went through a bunch
of emotions before you even get to move
the controller and use it right he he
shows you that he has an attitude yes
stand
wasn't you one of the first guys to
actually have uh uh the stand still
anime well besides sonic yeah
they existed but we spent a lot of time
on idols and like
yo-yos were really big in japan at one
point so one of the games he does a
yo-yo because he knew that would work
and like yeah
yeah i don't think
so so no no but it was really good with
you guys
this is great because
like i said you have that aggressive you
have that thing but like you said you
taught you hearing potentially what you
know the father of playstation is saying
you're hearing maybe there is some
trepidation that this character won't
catch over to japanese audiences so my
question is like
what do you do because obviously some
concessions have to be made to make that
acceptable i heard about the the hands
that you know the fingers you know crash
had to have bits you know what kind of
thing you hear about the dance stuff
like that but like what do you think
changed your time because even though we
love crash and crash ended up becoming
what it became initially the reviews
weren't strong
and and and what was crazy about it is
even though the reviews were like oh
it's trying to be what is this barrier
or
whatever
the sales said otherwise the the people
love
it
them
mario that's what people don't realize
like even though the reviews did what it
did it's it's what actually so my thing
is what do you think was the turning
point for one that audience and then two
the sales to to dominate
yeah so uh there's two things there the
first one was there was a magic moment
where sony was gonna sony japan finally
came in and was gonna decide whether or
not they were gonna make this an
international release or whether or not
it was just gonna be in north america
wow so they came in and you know we had
been the the work hours i i admit i was
a crunch person i regret it but we had
been up for like two days
working on getting the demo ready
because the game's not finished and they
came in and that you know the looks
just not just not like the aggressive
crash art is just not landing and i
remember like we were gonna run out to
lunch
and i went over to charlotte francis who
was our texture artist i believe she's
still at naughty dog she's absolutely
fantastic and charlotte was our like our
fastest she was she did textures and she
was really fast i was like charlotte
they keep talking about the mouth
keep talking about the eyes
make little pac-man eyes kind of anime
style get rid of the color and
everything else in in the eyes and you
got to get rid of the mouth close the
mouth and
she did the art we came back from lunch
she put it on the table and everyone
went
let's go
that might work
and that like charlotte francis save
crash bandicoot wow
wow she did it right and
what ended up getting marketed was
people who took that and ran with it and
the entire crash marketing campaign in
japan was absolutely brilliant and you
know the crash dance was like kind of
their thing and then like the whole
thing it was like it was genius but that
moment like led to it to it working out
wow and the second question you had now
i'm like on sale
uh sales beating mario so this is like
something to watch out for like
everyone loves mario and everyone loved
mario back then and we were uh
you know audacious enough to say we're
taking mario
and
a lot of people had a lot of like they
didn't like that they weren't feeling
bad and so and so i would go into
interviews and the interviews would be
like
how do you think you could take on mario
and i was answering i would answer the
question they look down on their page
for the next question they go so since
you are not going to be as good as mario
are you a medium bias they haven't even
played it right they've even played it
and so there was this whole like and
yeah we were aggressive and audacious
and we were not right so there was this
who the hell are you you made a couple
of games
and it was way of the warrior which had
terrible reviews also and like there's
no way this is going to work out
the reviews were i would say
and they never are that fair on that but
then like people were like i don't have
a choice i have a sony system i bought
it for matt and i bought it for whatever
i'm gonna i'm gonna try this oh god this
is this is good yeah and then like the
the people again the gamers
they were the ones that were like no
there's some magic here yeah and then
you know we made the second game and by
the time the second game comes out
you're naughty dog it's crash and like
all of the reviews go easier because
respect is good right yeah the respect
wasn't there and you know frankly we
probably didn't deserve it at that point
so so it's all good
you earned everything yeah that that
that conversation that he had and the
next question that it was so dismissive
from the first question
you earned that they treated you
different the next time they saw you
like this is like you have to understand
this is the way the world works right
when vr started coming out the first
question was so what tell us about vr
the second question is since nobody's
going to want vr
it's just the way it is right and then
like
it gets over hyped because people have
to hype it to and then it comes down and
then it slowly builds its way back up
here's a good one for you let's go
why do you think cds are going to be a
good way to develop games yeah well
because you've got all this memory
you've got this it's cheaper this is
going to be better for the developer
it's better than
load times
load times yes
you don't fit my current system like my
current rack like they look too much
like my music like the the number of
things that people come at you with that
they've already decided it's not going
to work you go you look at it in the
rearview mirror and you're like yeah of
course it worked look at the iphone
right good point good point newton comes
out people i laughed at andy andy had a
newton i was like who the hell needs a
screen and a computer and i got a
desktop look at the size
i need to carry it with me i don't want
it and you know when iphone came out
with no keyboard that's never going to
work
no it's not everybody knows where the
world is going you like
it takes a while to get used to things
and they got used to crash no doubt so
i just think we're talking about all of
these different sort of
ways in which people looked at crash and
said oh this is not going to work
compared to mario whatever when when you
say miyamoto was playing the game and he
looked at his eyes and it wasn't the
look of the game i think it's just the
fact that
gameplay is king and gameplay will
always be king whether it be 2.5 deep
would it be 3d 2d to me he looked at
that he looked at how well that game
controlled and that's where it was okay
now when you look at
how this this game controls in this sort
of 90 degree shift from from left to
right
it controls just as tight as a as a
mario platformer that to me was the
thing that obviously when as a kid i'm
seeing this game and i'm like the
graphics are amazing but if it didn't
control as well as it did
it wouldn't have mattered and for me
that was it so when i look at like
everything
when you look at
why these things are successful besides
the look and the change in sort of art
and and polygons and 3d and everything
to me is the game play that still kept
it to me because
you guys are still beginning you know
developers there so to get that right to
get that feel right
how is it that you like what what is
kind of what was your your design mantra
back then
right
so keep in mind a few things had changed
before crash bandicoot every game we
made was either out of our own pocket or
we had a very small budget that was too
small for the game we were trying to
make because no one trusts a bunch of
high school kids or whatever right
so even the stuff we were doing for ea
our games were half price quarter price
of any competing piece of software right
universal changed that with crash they
said what do you need oh and the first
thing was employees and people to help
us yes the other thing that we had as an
advantage is we had mark cerny who had
made
worked on it so he had some knowledge
and i just decided this game was going
to be the magnum opus like i was not
going to let it release until it was
perfect and
even in the jack days i would go into
andy's office and i would say something
changed you would say nothing changed
like the control is not good we're
starting over wow the control is
everything in games control is you have
to
get out of your way and empower you at
the same time exactly and if you're
thinking about it or if it doesn't act
like it needs to act it kills you and we
just learn things for example you know i
said people were saying how when you're
running in are you going to know where
the edge is to jump like it's just not
it's not going to be easy the answer to
that was even as you start falling into
the pit you have a couple of frames the
jump jump to jump
because you can see you're falling and
you jump and you're like [ __ ] i'm too
late
you're good
rewind
let's reengineer that absolutely you
know trepidation but you do jump and you
get the jump because we gave you those
extra couple of frames and there's all
these little things that we learned as
we were going we also it's dynamically
difficult to adjust there's dynamic
difficulty adjustment in it a boulder
comes at you you die it comes at you
slower you die it comes at you slower
you die eventually you're going to make
it oh so he was helping me and i didn't
even know it yeah
all over the place and those were things
we had never thought of doing before but
you know with mark and everybody else we
did it and so like it just worked out
i'm kind of curious like right now
obviously you know um crash bandicoot is
being made by another person uh you know
is it weird you know even though that
you've moved on from that
position even you know out of the
industry to a point you know you
obviously you're at meadow but that now
that you're not the helm of uh you know
a studio like that is it weird seeing
someone else can you watch it can you
look at crash the same
no
but i haven't played
any of the crashes since i made crap
wow okay
and there was like the the recent ones
have been well received so at least
the last one actually a lot of people
liked exactly there was this
trough where like the kid left home and
then i don't want to talk about their
career like you know
like went downhill and you were like oh
my god
you knew everything that came out was
going to be embarrassing and i i
just couldn't play this stuff so the new
stuff that has come out
i haven't played much of it
do you want to skip over that part where
you know that that that you know and
then we get to jack we go yeah we listen
to the final i swear because i got a
shout out
well those two things are related right
like we've been signed with universal so
universal owned crash because we made a
deal with universal that they own crash
bandicoot and if you follow it universal
was you know was bought and then that
was bought and that was bought now it's
activision right like yeah microsoft
microsoft owners
if it closes with you closer to the ftc
which is ironic think about it it's
going from sony to right
yeah
yeah but in any event like
that that made us decide that we didn't
want to continue working on crash
because universal was like at that point
mark had left universal there wasn't
much they were bringing to the table and
yet they still wanted a lot of you know
the royalties from the game right i can
understand i can understand that again
arrogantly inaudible we'll just do it
again with a new character
let's go hardware
you guys had full creative control with
crash outside i know some things like
was the influence i wanted to get this
question from um lord will from uh lords
of gamer he wanted to know like
was it was sony really influenced like
influencing everything about crash or
was it just on the japanese side before
you move into the jackson next text i
just wanted to ask that question as far
as influence control didn't know they
was making it right yeah they didn't
know that like crash was already
designed by the time sony saw it gotcha
i think the the only person that had
influ well i said you know you had
charles embolus and joe pearson who were
doing 2d the 2d sketches i unfortunately
don't have one behind me i could go run
in the closet and grab my original
protection
they had a huge influence on the game
because they set the tone and they they
did the 2d art that became crash
bandicoot right so they certainly were
there but in terms of the 3d game
it was really mark cerny and the eight
people that were in naughty dog that was
the beginning of crash
what sony did is they took the crash
bandicoot that we built effectively for
non-japanese world and they made it work
for japan from a marketing standpoint we
did a few things that you mentioned the
mint yeah
four-fingered things look like the
yakuza had a yakuza yeah
so there were there were things that we
changed for japan
uh but most of it was actually not in
the game most of the changes there were
changes like we had instructions and
akuaku did some different stuff but like
most of the changes were their marketing
gotcha and that's where they really did
a lot of the work gotcha on on jack
let's go there was a lot more
collaboration with sony in terms of the
design and to a certain extent i would
say in the end that it ended up being a
weakness not because sony didn't have
good ideas
there's nothing against the people that
were doing it or the ideas they came up
with it was the fact that i thought okay
now we're making an international
uh
you know superstar this has to work all
over the world and all over the world
there's a lot of cultures with a lot of
beliefs it's not just the japan and rest
of the world thing i want to make this
work everywhere and sony by that time
was a big organization they had a middle
eastern unit they had their latin
american unit they had all these and so
i was like here's a genius idea
everybody will come together and review
everything as we're building it because
we're already working with sony and
we'll figure out the best possible
answer that fits everybody and i regret
that decision because i think it waters
down the character
crash had the the the vibrancy of a very
small number of people yes working
really hard with an opinion
and jack
has some of that and i love jack and
daxter and i'm but
you know dollar to dollar
not as strong a character in my opinion
because we took too many people's advice
again not the people not sony right it's
just that if you get too many people in
a room you're gonna water it down and it
is i took that away and like
up until today i believe that like true
art is a very small number of very very
intense people working with a vision and
it's going to offend someone i don't
mean offend like yes
too many chefs
i don't like your character design that
won't work in this country and things
like that and you're going to go i don't
care right i'm going to make it and
you're going to make it work and that
works for crash in japan and if it can
work you know japanese market is very
insular if it works for japan anyone can
you know give or take
that's a good point oh so like spyro was
never going to sell in the middle east
because at the time dragons were fantasy
characters and that wasn't allowed
saudi arabia for example but crash was a
bandicoot and that was real so that was
okay so there
no no no right yeah but like beyond that
kind of rules like
design with a spirit design with your
voice you may crash in a vacuum um and
this is in your rebellious stage because
you actually y'all
um
did you
did you want jack and dexter to be in
that same rebellious stage without all
the eyes because i know you you alluded
to that part right then you you regret
the decision of having more people input
um if if you could go back
that you would eliminate that and
what do you think jack and dexter would
have turned out to what what what's
missing
that you would have just let it be yeah
so
let me let me answer that in a
roundabout way right okay so crash
bandicoot was a sonic mario game like we
wanted to make a character action game
but we also had this fundamental belief
that cds were going to change the way
gaming worked and gaming was going to go
from
purely
interface and gameplay to storytelling
and start competing with medium like
movies in like you know telling stories
creating worlds and like being much
deeper and so when we started working on
crash we had a vision for something that
looked more like uncharted not in the
sense that it was a human character not
in the sense that like uh you know it
was it was more adult it was still a
character action game but we had these
cut scenes planned and we had a
backstory and we were gonna go back and
forth and like
the first uh the first boss you were you
were gonna jump up cut to a cut scene go
through his roof he was gonna threaten
you and then it was gonna start we
utterly failed to do any of this because
you know
the tech just wasn't there absolutely so
when jack and daxter came and
playstation two came we were on this
journey to make this mix of
game
and story we wanted to
play right hashtag
let's go
so
one of the things we had decided with
crash is crash wouldn't talk and the
reason that crash doesn't talk was
because gex and a bunch of other games
had come out and took advantage of all
the memory
to have speaking characters but didn't
get it right and you were like that
wasn't funny i don't want to hear that i
don't think i'm this character like and
you distance yourself from the character
dana gould
we were like
let's not gex this character let's make
him silent
[Laughter]
i think it was the right thing to do
because it's you everyone else talks to
crash crash doesn't talk right
here i had a lack of vision
playstation 2 comes out
i couldn't get over that and i was like
it worked for crash let's keep jack
quiet
and if you look at jack one him they'll
talk a lot
but we also wanted the attitude yeah
that's what created dexter
because baxter can say whatever the hell
he wants to say
it's not you
yeah like he's the annoying sidekick yes
right and so that was the solution to
that problem
and because of that i think jack didn't
have the attitude he could have had
because we transferred it to dexter and
that's like a little bit more mellow of
a character because we didn't we didn't
need two attitudes right we had an
attitude dexter was all of the you know
wise talking and sassiness and back
talking and like he told the story and
like he was there so jack got a little
too quiet
and
we didn't really ever fix that with jack
he started talking a little more but he
doesn't say a lot and like you know yeah
uncharted they fix that right and if you
look at uncharted it is literally that
line to story and game together with the
additional decision that they were going
to do non-character action game more
adult human being characters which we
wanted to do instead of jack two
but sony wanted more jack oh
wow
oh i didn't know that okay
just out of curiosity did you ever
consider like ratchet and clank like a
rival in any way
so insomniac uh and ted price yes we're
close friends absolutely um they had
also signed with universal and for a
long time our offices were right next to
their offices
with them and we talked to them and
everything else right and so
um it was it was really crash and spyro
remember yes at the beginning right i'm
sorry
one thing we realized early on or at
least i realized early on is they
shouldn't both come out in the holiday
because we were just you know they were
both great games why attack each other
but the holiday was where the you know
action was and so we ended up with
posters that had both you know both
crash and
so ratchet and clank was it competition
yes but at the same time they were our
best friends and we were very close with
that team and we shared technology back
and forth between the two teams and to
this day ted is a close friend and like
it's kind of like you know in the nba
you get on the court your rivals but
after the court that's still your man no
no i get that together right
yeah
yeah i get it it's one of those things
where it's like there's a rivalry there
but it's nothing but respect like yeah
absolutely and then you not to mention
that that helps build each build both of
you up both companies it's like oh i see
you it's like it's like i'm gonna do
something like that yeah it was an
interesting time because jason made a
good point
we forgot at that time solve like
everything was kind of like pushed
towards the holiday season you had to
kind of drop it around the holiday
season
yeah you're crunching and stuff like
that but that's when the spending yeah
so the thing now here's the the question
that i have for you the one i really
couldn't wait to ask you is that
logic like naughty dog at this point
crash the sequels
team racing then you have playstation 2
you have jack jack dexter the hits are
coming you got naughty dog is now
becoming a thing synonymous with quality
and these great games and i got a pocket
watch i know the checks had to be very
nice
at that point so
we were doing very well yes yes so so my
question now is like
what you then do
in my opinion
it's kind of unheard of like you kind of
leave on top so so my question is like
what made you get out the game at that
point and say you know what it's time
for me and andy baby to walk away from
this thing when literally you're like
the the top of the unit you're the
darlings right and then to say we're
going to necessarily sell our company
and then obviously doing dog continues
to be what naughty dog is the iconic
naughty dog but it's just interesting to
me what was the mindset at that point
for you
yeah so
yeah
crazy times like andy and i were
you know the checks were massive like
everybody was it's a small company still
so everyone in the company was doing
extremely well like we were just
we were doing really well and you know
at some point i remember we were in
tokyo in roppongi in uh in a bar called
the lexington queen
probably 4 a.m i don't remember but it
was certainly way way past midnight
bottle whiskey in front of us i drank
back then i don't drink it
salute whiskey
andy and me
kelly flock
who ran the internal sony studios
and annie mcnamara and andy reiner of
game and former magazine so that was the
people around the table 4am lexington
queen and
i i was lit like we were all
it was a nice town it was a nice time
kelly kelly goes
so when are you selling what what he
goes the company
i go why would we sell the company
exactly and
and andy mcnamara and andy reiner too
they get up and they're like let me tell
you about naughty dog
they care about the games they care they
don't need to sell to anybody they they
say that and kelly flat goes yeah but
you're number one there ain't nowhere to
go but down yeah
yeah
i remember
i was like
it's like maybe we should someone what
when we good good so so so is that okay
i'm sorry
yeah so the other thing that was going
on is and and this is the part like
there are things i regret about the
naughty dog era and one of the things i
regret was like you got to remember i
started when i was 15. yeah i studied i
didn't take i didn't take training to be
a manager i didn't i was never in a
company where i was managed right so
to me
we talked about the holidays you had to
hit the holiday because if you didn't
hit the holiday
you could hit next holiday but that's
way too long and you've cut in half the
amount of money you can make and the
number of games you can make the naughty
dog we finished crash on a christmas
we
hit crash two the next holiday
product that's great that's cool we hit
crash three the next one that was even
shorter
we did like eight months and four days
it was like insane wow the cadence is
nuts
that's insane and yes the money was
there but it was there for me and andy
and the team but the team was not
getting what andy and i did and we
worked all the time and i regret like we
slept under desks we were there six days
seven days a week there was two years
where i did not have a day out of the
office
andy andy had we our computers tracked
it 16 hour average days wow wow that
includes weekends
and one day out of the office because i
had the flu and i took one day at home
and he didn't take a day out in 1998.
wow
you know i'm in my 20s right 98 i'm 28.
yeah we started making crash and started
working these hours when i was 24.
you were cut forward to jack and daxter
it didn't stop
and we started giving the team time off
in between the projects we give them a
month off
and i would go on press tour oh yeah and
then i'd have to get in there
i have to start working on the next game
that's still work yeah
i had no life preaching and like there
was a time where i remember like
i had a girlfriend she was like
like just out this on your i had a
girlfriend she was not a great person it
turns out but she got something right i
cared so much about the games i was
making i cared about my pc i cared about
the car i would go out with swabs and
like you know clean out the car and
detail it but my body was just falling
apart
mentally
i was like
not the man i am today and i just you
know sitting in the bar with kelly flock
i was like
he's right like there's nowhere to go up
and also like when am i gonna get a life
preach so i just kind of at some point
decided and
keep in mind also the companies had been
growing all across the industry but
nobody at verdict had started doing you
know it was still like the two leads or
one lead or three leads would run
everybody and there was no organization
and i didn't know what to do i was not
like see what we need is an art lead and
the art lead will have departments and
the departments will have like all this
stuff that exists today
i didn't know how to do any of that and
i was like this isn't gonna work out
like it started with an eight-person
team with crash and now we're a
80-person team and like just
all these people and i go to everyone
and it's like i just got to this point
where i was like
i think i need to take his time i think
his time and there's no way to take time
off when you're hitting holidays yeah
and you're doing this stuff and like
i also i like i had evan wells that was
working there stephen white at the time
working at naughty dog kristoff like all
these really and like they were saying
how does my career progress
right
you've created a structure where i'm
really in charge like like maybe i
should go start my own team and like law
firms break up right and my father i saw
that his whole life and i'm like i don't
want like a third of the team or
whatever to split off
i just don't want that this is a this is
a powerhouse
if i step aside
it could go evan can step up okay so we
agreed to sell okay
we agreed to make the jack games
and about two years into a four-year
contract i told sony look i think i need
i need to walk the earth i need i need
to have a life after that i don't know
if andy's going to do it too he ended up
deciding to do the same thing it took
two years from the day i said that to
the day i left to transition to evan and
at the time stephen white running the
company
last year evan had the big office and i
had the second
biggest office like we we did the
transition
and i went right though yeah i just
needed time no i knew it's a powerful
discussion because you know obviously
you mentioned the the the the let's be
honest we got to call it the the crunch
of the industry and then you know the
other thing to find is interesting
especially in parallel to this climate
now where you're seeing a lot of
companies selling and a lot of people
being acquired right would you say that
because i know i'm kind of
affectionately known as lord acquisition
they always tease me like oh there's
always pro acquisition but would you say
that like
that's part of the end game you know
when from where you came from for a lot
of a lot of these studio heads to say
okay we got to that point we've done
everything we can and then it's like hey
let's cash out let's grab a margarito to
be like we we've we've accomplished our
goal or is that too much is that far
from like what you think about that only
cashing out like i'm not pro and i'm not
anti for a while i was pro and i
remember saying to ted when are you
selling
i said i'm never gonna sell this company
i'm gonna i love managing i'm gonna do
this i'm gonna do that and for a while
like there are hard years running
companies and for a while i was like
yeah i made the right decision
look what this guy's going through still
my friend
and
then he sold the sony recently and let's
just say the valuations for companies
but he also had
15 20 years in that period where he was
working his ass off and i was
traveling and doing whatever i was doing
and i did a lot of other things i wrote
the comic books these characters and
like so
who did it right i don't know
maybe someday in heaven and we'll talk
about it but like you did what was right
for yourself for yourself
a question you see how uh the industry
is going now with the anti-crush
movement a crunch movement and that's
right that's the right thing for them
for the industry to do it
i take that verb
implementations uh to
uh stave that to to to
actually don't allow too much crunch to
happen but
the trends now in the digital era as far
as release dates remember you were
saying that the holiday season uh
everything was geared towards the
holiday season we see games like elden
ring can come out in uh february march
and they can actually have big numbers
and big sales so we see the trends uh
lead that there is actually no selling
period it's just good games that can
actually sell when they actually do
release uh do you think that is uh a
good trend going forward because the old
trend was everything was geared towards
the holiday the beginning of the year
was barren and now that leads to a hell
of a lot of crunch so crunch at that
period of time was actually necessary
but now crunch isn't necessary in this
digital era and do you think the digital
era is the reason why crunch isn't
necessary anymore there's still a lot of
teams crunching and i you know it's this
is a really hard topic like at the end
of the day you start every project
spending too much time
on the details and not getting to the
com you know not getting the things you
need done and then whatever you do you
have a release date and it comes and you
end up delaying and like it there is
still crunch in the industry and still
people managing around i think the
holidays have become less important it
kind of depends on where you are in the
business though i think the holidays are
far less important if you're a mobile
game yeah
relevant holidays are still important on
consoles it's still important for us in
vr um whether or not that leads to
crunch or not depends on how skilled
your managers are and how reasonable you
are about the fact that sometimes extra
time is the right thing to do i thought
it was like we always hit our date like
i didn't think it was possible to slip
the date there were teams at that time
that were releasing a lot more slowly
you know if you look at the uh gran
turismo team you had like idols across
i think two maybe one across all of
playstation we were doing every year and
so
one of their titles may have outsold us
because the next year it was the only
title and the year after that it was the
only one right right but we outsold them
if you look at the
some of the titles we did and that was
the right thing to do financially but
again it was it was brutal
to be honest back then there's like a
gray area to the industry wasn't the
young you didn't know what could be done
what couldn't be done and like you know
all that was done back then that led to
the industry what it is yeah yeah so so
that's my question jason like um because
you know obviously the the dice speech
felt like it was you venting what you
were feeling right
some bars
no i mean but but again you were
speaking from the heart and anytime you
do that that is the truth and you know
don't ever regret doing that
but it is
did you feel you said you crunched a lot
but it almost felt like that was your
motivation to do it did you feel that it
was something that it it was kind of
self-imposed but then publishers looked
the other way or was there something in
the in the sort of culture of the
company that that kind of
egg kind of egged you towards doing that
was it understood that that was the
expectation or was it just the fact that
you guys were young hungry and willing
to do this
let me let me start by saying i take
full responsibility for the crunching
i think a lot of teams were crunching i
think a lot of teams didn't know how to
do things differently differently it was
accepted if it was known by publishers
but at the end of the day it was my
responsibility
to set rational timelines
and i was always too aggressive and then
i hit them and so
i you know
i'm not going to excuse it by saying
they were they were mitigating
circumstances like others were doing it
too i still should have been better i
feel that i feel that no you guys was
hitting your target targets without
the the but it creates the expectation
that's what it's supposed to be yeah but
i'm i'm not even talking about that they
weren't hitting their target with being
efficient without the bugs and stuff
like that like now you have game
breaking bugs that are in in this
digital area
but but it's like ship it now
fix it later
right
you we couldn't
yeah you couldn't fix it later it wasn't
back then it was the one
on a cd or it was on a dvd like if you
if you had i think it was
crash two one of the titles we we put
out and like did you know you're like oh
my god the thing is on the shelf we made
it you know and then we get a call from
sony and they're like we've had like
three bugs there's crashes it's crashing
and like you're like ah and that was it
just those three for 24 hours like
you've got to recall your cds
and then ship everyone's cds and not
everybody knows there's a bug like you
can't do live patching like you right
right good point you had to get it right
because if you didn't get it right there
was no yeah it was just impractical
to fix it and so it in a lot of cases
you just pulled the game from the shelf
if it was that bad a bug because you
couldn't sell it anymore because we had
to get it right live you know
live operations that's another thing
that's making crunch a little less
relevant if you can launch your game
into a beta learn if it's working or not
slowly build it mark it into it like and
fix the problems after it's launched
like these are all things that allow
holidays and things like that to become
less important but back then you had
none of that it was even worse on a
cartridge yes because remember it was an
18 piece of plastic and silicon
screw
i do have a quick question as like an
outsider i don't know if you want to
comment on this like you see like a lot
of these companies buying like giant
corporations uh you know you see people
buying smaller studios mid-sized studios
to even publishers a lot of this
consolidation do you as someone that's
been in the industry feel like that's
good for the industry
yes it's
there's an endless cycle and um
this is actually something i probably
can't answer today that's right there's
a lot going on there's a lot going on
like you know in case you didn't feel
comfortable answering i don't want to
put you yeah that's good
i knew the chat would get on me if i
didn't yeah you know
but i want to transition so now like i
said you step away you sell you know you
make the decision for your mental health
you make the decision to see the world
you know but there were some stops along
the way you did you know the comment
like
that the thq run you know
you had fox buy spades like there's a
lot going on so you know my question is
through all those experiences when you
were away
what did you learn and then what in the
hell made you say
vr all right so
i am very bad at retirement
he was retired for a good six months
before i started noodling on things um
there's a bunch i did that it's not
worth bringing up today but like tried
to acquire some game companies was
involved in a bunch of other stuff but
ultimately myspace kind of hit
and uh my face was fire but it was dope
like that
right and so i i was making my page look
good and i had friends some friends that
were celebrities and they're like can
you make my page look good because you
know i got a lot of followers and i was
like sure i can make your page real good
and i would do it i was like this is
this is laborious like
[Laughter]
so what if somebody made something that
could plug into a myspace page and it
just made it look better and they could
put photos up and effects and like it
could edit videos because like and so i
went i actually knew the head of
marketing in myspace i'm like i think
you guys should build this and she's
like well we're not going to build that
we're
busy and i was like well then i'll build
it and i'll sell it to you okay
and we did
i said hold on
hold pause but
build a home
a year and 10 days after we started that
company we sold it to myspace and like
their whole thing was we're going to use
this to like is the center piece of how
our video is going to work and it was
going to do a bunch of stuff and it was
like great what about this facebook and
they're like ah yeah this is good
companies like you know they're getting
bigger but there's no way facebook we're
myspace i mean
by the time we sold the company it went
from that kind of dismissiveness to well
they're getting bigger but we think in
the long run we've got and then by the
time we actually started working on
things from myspace it was like all
hands on deck and then a few months
later it was like clear that
my space was gone
and so yeah it was a short tenure at
myspace but i did learn a lot about
social networks i learned a lot about
you know that kind of software i just
it was a good learning experience and
you know we sold a company so it was it
was fine
the comic books
over there too
so i gotta ask i'll tell you listen to
the comics the comics were i have this
creative thing that i want to fulfill
i don't have a venue to do it i didn't
want to start a game team
i want to do something with a small team
of creative people because that to me
was the glory days of game making was a
small team of creative people and it
turns out that comics are still a small
team of really creative talented people
i love music i'm going to write a comic
book and i'm going to figure out how to
get it made i did that twice with two
comic book series they were okay you
know as a writer i'm not
you're learning you're not
[Music]
and let me ask you a question uh okay
well you know i'm always gonna actually
by the way both of those the goal was
i'm gonna write a comic book series and
then i'm going to make a movie about it
i wrote the comic book series and then i
started going around in hollywood and
they're like comic books
nobody ever knows what's going on and
then i'm like yeah it's going to be
r-rated because the stuff that i wrote
was a little and they're like no no no
no the comic book movie stuff all has to
be pg
the secret see it's got to be pg and
then you look at you know the stuff
that's out there
you have deadpool
yep you have always been at the curve
ahead of the curve
and
and you've always followed that
aggressive thought like you said you
can't retire probably right
so you're sitting there you're like you
know what today i'm a drug
it's aggressive it's aggressive and it's
optimistic yeah so so with that i have
to ask the question
when you join thq
here we go you joined
what was essentially a sinking ship at
the time
how optimistic were you that you could
turn it around somewhat and
the company still sort of survived that
and then what do you feel about the
modern thq tsq nordic kind of coming
back in
in funny ways trying to sort of
recapture what thq was back then
yeah so i i had i was involved in
the acquisition of a much larger
publisher than thq
um
and i would have been ahead of studios
and that didn't go through we didn't it
didn't happen but i spent about a year
on that acquisition and then the same
bankers
said well what else is out there and i
was like it's it's that's kind of it
right everything else is appropriately
valued or whatever they're like what
about thq and i was like
i mean they've got good teams they have
good teams but man that you know it was
yeah stock it was a two billion dollar
company that was worth something like 25
million dollars in the market at that
time wow
you could say you could buy them for 25
million but it doesn't quite work like
that because there's debt and all this
other stuff going on and
if there's one thing i've learned in
life i don't ever want to go through a
bankruptcy again
but i i was close with bankers and here
was the thesis like here's the idea
video game developers
are becoming more and more valuable
and the industry is getting larger and
larger
starting a big developer starting a
talented large organization like a
naughty dog is harder than it's ever
been because it was fine when it was
eight people it was hard when it was 16
it got harder at 60. now they're
hundreds like these teams are hard to
make and so forget thq forget the
current products the teams have value
these are talented teams and they'll be
able to make great stuff so all we got
to do this plane is headed to the ground
it's got a little bit of fuel but not a
lot dude it's got it no don't land it
scrape the wheels off
auger into the ground like that's all we
got to do we got to raise enough money
that the plane will have enough that it
can just
get rid of everything that isn't core to
the teams like those teams and like take
off from there and at some point that's
going to be worth billions of dollars
again wow that was a thesis that was
ambitious so
we started working on that i i went into
thq and i was like tell me everything
you got i went and visited all the teams
and i was like this is going to be
really like we're going to
really bounce off but we can do this
and within a week of joining the company
it was clear there wasn't as much money
as we thought there were other
mitigating factors there were titles
that they had shown me 10 minutes of
gameplay and they had 12. and i got half
the game done right they were wow
and nobody at thq central knew how
poorly the games had come along but know
anything about games you eventually get
into it within weeks it was like
okay we're gonna hit the ground heart
yeah there is no way this is gonna be we
did manage to raise money in what's
called a stocking horse
yep
bottom line
very close
but we ended up having to go through the
bankruptcy and we sold off all the
companies now those teams
is what you're referring to for the most
part along with some ip as thq nordic
right and those themes you know whether
it's the forays or the you know all
those teams
they have in fact gone on to be
incredibly valuable and the products
that they brought out
did much better than we thought they
would do when they sold to the new
companies and some of those teams a lot
of those teams in fact
ended up working with me on vr early on
because they said you did the right
thing by us as a team you cared about
people and like so at the end of the day
ghq was a very bad eight nine months
very hard like talk about not sleeping
again no um
yeah no that's powerful way it goes
teens exist and that might not have
happened it may have been a different
chapter seven chapter eleven it's very
complicated but it might have been
everybody's lost their job going all
right everybody's off to the windows
fluffed out to nothing yeah no this this
is powerful and i love these learning
experiences and and how candid you are
with it and the thing too is like now
like i said you you talking about vr
we're talking about like oculus right
and let's get to it you know for me i'll
be honest and king you know laugh at
cloud i mean rightfully so you know
i was the hater i'm a gen xer i was just
like i don't because i saw like early
tech stuff i'm like early earlier than
like samsung gear or something and i'm
like
yeah and i'm like man i don't know about
this right so
it wasn't until the quest 2k right
and then i was like all right let me try
it at least right and i try and i'm like
oh
first steps
you know putting
the gun together manipulating objects in
the room and i think for me it was
seeing my hands
i was just like oh this is okay you know
what i mean and you're messing around so
like you know
then i'm like again core gamer
sensibilities this is cool
but what about the games though right
like where what about the game so and i
think me and you talked about this while
jason went um i was like i'm such a
turn-based guy and i remember
put some i think shout out to uh lord
bill stillwell
formerly at meta and then now i believe
that um epic but
he was like you got to try dbm
and i'm like all right let me see what's
going on the dungeons and dragons four
player co-op and i remember picking up
the piece and just like manipulating it
and i'm just like okay this is different
so i'm like let me get let me get the
guys together let's see if am i feeling
like this feels transformative and then
it's like you got that another one for
me was um shout out i believe uh raymond
uh zenith zenith the mmo
anime style melee combat and i'm like
man this is like almost fantasy star
online with final fantasy and i'm in
this world and i the idea put my hands
and i'm flying around this world i'm
like okay
this is different and then obviously
the resident evils the lone echoes
he transformed
[Music]
literally virtual boy yes yes i brought
the virtual boy in um my
popping off all over the place i.e the
shades um
but i always believed in that tech i
always believed in the
entering the world i started off with
vetrex okay so
you know we can go back all the way talk
about it
now
the tech sega had uh some vr that they
were coming out and i was i was very
hyped for that sega vr but it never and
never you know got off the ground
so now when we get to this just the
oculus and i was on oculus before meta
purchased them
and i'm trying to tell these guys yo you
got to get in there yep you got to check
it out at this period of time it's a lot
of horror games jump scares um
rudimentary stuff but still stuff that
you know there's a foundation here
there's something here and there's
there's there's cultivation here like
the early stages of pong the early
stages of a pitfall right just this
stuff here we're we're in the the the
huawei west of it but it's gonna form
into something that's gonna be fantastic
and it's gonna take certain key games
are gonna make this happen
and i'm trying to tell these guys here
check it out check it out
this guy calls me
and he's he's raving i'm like what the
hell are you raving about what what are
you talking about yodemio oh yo and i'm
like man i'll talk to you in the morning
i'll talk to you in the morning because
i'm dismissing you now because you just
missed me for a long time sure that
every show we went to yeah
yeah
we at pax and i'm fighting with these
guys we got to do the vr stuff and they
like you go do the vr stuff
i would make them do all the vr coverage
and i'm going to the vr stuff but okay
all right fine i know what's going to
happen it's going to hit he calls me he
tells me that
and i told him well i don't have the um
the oculus too
and this is when i know he's serious
i got a package at myself
i said well bottom you brought her i was
like everybody gotta experience this i
said i didn't order it you only have a
few billion more people that need that
are you really like but it's gonna hit
it's gonna hit it's gonna hit and i'm
like i didn't order anything what the
hell is this
open it up let's go let's get it let's
get it together go
every game every console needs a killer
app
and i've played eric i i have the vive
i had the original oculus
i've played i put nodes on the floor i
have the playstation vr i did all of
that stuff this stuff was untethered yes
that was the key for me very very key
i'm playing demo with these dudes and we
all in the same room and i got a
giddyness about me a giddiness
like you know when we look over you and
you can see them over there i see them
we all in the same space
because before vr was isolated incident
for me
now it's a group thing we went to a
concert
with khalifa concert we watched emma
made everybody took up the venues i took
him out like it was it was it was a
thing
so i i can't wait for him to make that
transition to you but i want to know i
wanted to tell you that how it
transformed a group because attic was
not into vr at all i literally had to
lose a win a bet with him to put him in
vr yes
to do an interview right yeah remember
it was on interview
i think it was e3 i think said e3
oh that packs okay yeah it was packs and
he he did it and he was like yeah yeah
does i get like motion sickness really
easy in vr for some reason so like i
have to play like demeo is like the only
game like i tried resident evil and that
it's just like i could only play like
maybe 15 20 minutes of the game but like
demio i was like i turned around and my
girlfriend's off work at midnight i'm
like oh
oh and i'm like this is like this is
probably an hour before we finish this
i'm like we good like
no that was again i was like for him
because attic is a test bed for me you
know this young one and
i was like okay at least he gets it and
he was enjoying himself and i was just
like okay and i know how resistant he
he's more resistant than i was so i
wanted to transition all of our
experiences just to say like for you
like
what was that moment to say okay this is
where i want to go now korea this this
is where this could the industry might
shape in this direction
yep so i can definitely answer that so
uh
i'm doing this on the side i haven't you
know gotten
oculus is comms you know met his
comments department who agrees so i'm
going to talk general time we're not
going to talk about yes i'm sure they
would be okay with it we just have to
get i can come back
266 you said or something yeah
yeah we just come back shortly yes um
so
there's there's a you know we've talked
about how i have a vision i go for
things i do it so i'm gonna i'm gonna
before i answer the oculus specific the
vr specific questions yes let me just
say this like if there's takeaways for
people today it's this like first of all
one of the biggest reasons people don't
succeed at doing stuff is they never
start if you have an idea if you believe
in something
start preach once you've started you'll
find if you don't know where to start
start on something make a title screen
do whatever because once you get started
you start rolling you start going the
second thing is you got to be okay with
shipping it you got to be okay with
putting it out
and the third thing is you got to be
okay with failure we've been talking
about the things i've done today that
have succeeded there have been a lot of
things that i've done that have failed
some of them in smoking wrecks
that's okay as long as you walk away
from it
you're fine thq is a good example of
that walk away from it it was a failure
i consider it a failure but i learned a
lot and there's good people that i
worked with that i still work with in
virtual reality so when when i
after thq brendan who was the ceo of
oculus called me and said you got to see
this you got to come down here and see
us and i was like
okay i mean theoretically i think vr is
cool i've tried all the you know
last 20 years they all sucked but i'll
come back and look at it
i came down and looked at it and it blew
me away
not the very specific thing i was doing
but the potential yes i believed in the
potential everything i had ever made was
either through a screen
in a book
you never were there and remember why i
got into this business i got into this
business to make worlds
it's great to make worlds through a
screen it's great to make worlds on
pages but what if you could make a world
you could step into
and so i believe and fundamentally still
believe
that is the power of vr mr ar all of
these things is that you will be able to
step into worlds that otherwise you
could not step into and do things you
otherwise could not do whether it's
climb empress
be an amoeba travel to mars like
whatever it is it doesn't matter and the
point is to put you in somewhere else
and so
mr
oh
mr is mixed reality so it's like okay
you're in a headset you see the outside
world but you have to have stuff on top
it's like
i'm just making sure i follow the
terminology yeah you're good you're good
because i know ar and ovr yeah but he
said mr i'm like what are y'all doing
it's not complicated and there's too
many r's and yeah
but here's the thing get started okay
believe in yourself be yourself
be okay with failure
and those three principles i went into
this with i said no to brendan he said
you want a job i was like no you don't
have enough money to launch this i've
worked at sony you can't launch hardware
but i'm gonna go start what are you
gonna start
i don't know andy and i went up into an
attic with jason k another partner of
ours and we started talking about what
vr games would look like in the future
we were going to start a vr game company
then brendon called back and he said
and that was getting started did that
happen no brandon called back and said
you heard it was like yeah
facebook's going to buy you you have the
money now
[Laughter]
you want a job now i joined that was a
very expensive mistake
joined earlier but
believed
started
yep went with it don't care about
failure i still fundamentally believe
like i i don't want to get into too much
discussion about you know
the current products because again i'm
happy to come back again
happy place right now but like in
general
was the first video game machine what
you have today with playstation 5 xbox
or pc good point hell no good point did
i believe in games back then yes i was
the nerd that hid it from everybody else
but i believe that eventually and i said
this in early interviews with crash
bandicoot this won't be bigger than
music this will be bigger than film this
will be bigger than television and
people laughed and sure enough
where is it today they're making films
about kansas right it's like this this
is the future the metaverse all these
things these are the futures so i
believed i was willing to take the risks
and i got started and i'm okay with
failure and i fundamentally believe what
it looks like in 20 years you'll be
looking back at these early things that
we're doing and saying that was just
like the apple ii or the channel
or the nintendo was it worthwhile to do
nintendo when it was out yeah was it
worthwhile doing apple ii yeah should
you wait for the ultimate system no no
no not on a lot of cool and i totally
accept and understand the motion
sickness then yeah
that will also get better and we'll do
better at it and there are a lot of
things you can play now try the room yes
yes now respect you lord jason again
we're gonna put you to spot with any
more questions on that front but i'm
glad you said that as far as taking the
risks and
and seeing
as a visionary where this thing can go
and like you said you make a fantastic
point there were always stages you know
we're talking about gaming and we're
looking at now you know these you know
amazing experience the graphic fidelity
but look it you had to start somewhere
before you get there and the
advancements in and those inflection
points with certain games and moments
and that's what i think you're going at
with vr and i think you're onto
something there so
question five questions i had for you
was um just in reference to the back up
a bit it's all kind of looted but one of
the things i'm kind of proud of you and
i know you may look at it very cringy
but i think i was probably with the
summit conference we have to go back
there because
at the time in my opinion you know
king we come from that era
where
when you get the cartridge or whatever
the publisher is on the box the
publisher
is the one that gets the credit it's all
about the part like now like i'm
extremely pro-deaf right so now we're at
a part where we're like okay
we know that's you know ready at dawn we
know that's resolution games that did
that and i go out my way to seek out the
dev because these are the creators those
are the artists right all right don't
get me wrong no disrespect to my
publishers love you guys necessary love
you guys too and you guys help keep the
vision sometimes the lights on and we
love you but we got to give credit to
the creators like this is artistry to me
so when i saw your comments and i was
like i remember it was very
controversial at the time because one
naughty dog you're on top of the world
you're technically it's not to your
advantage really to be saying any of
these things because you're on top so my
question is one what led to that moment
and two
are you satisfied because you made
powerful points about hey we need to
give these devs their flowers their
recognition and know who they are
especially the playing thing that would
play i like that but i'll just be real
so where are you at looking back at it
now after those statements have to dice
up it yeah
really quickly on vr because i i've been
watching the chat out of the corner of
my eyes like talk about high resolution
graphics yes yes er psvr
yes yes yes
and then like you know standalone no
cable
so the answer to which one of those is
more important is yes they both are yeah
again remember vr is gonna move and
right now
cable free is awesome high resolution
graphics are awesome hard to get both of
those things together at a reasonable
price point reasonable price point also
awesome because then everyone can
experience it yeah it will all work
itself out like it nobody is
disrespecting the other hardware's we're
all just taking different stabs at it
and ultimately you will have all of
those that i promise technology will get
there you will have all of those in one
device and there will still be
competition but you will have all of it
in a device and you won't have to make a
choice no doubt um so with regards to
that dice conversation
again i've always been a believer in
interactive entertainment and the
metaverse and all of these things i
didn't call it the metaverse back then
but i always believed that there would
be these massive worlds everyone would
be in and i always believed it'd be
bigger than film and i'd be
believed it would be bigger than music
and bigger than television and all these
other things i also believe
fundamentally it's not that different
from those things like ultimately it is
an artistry and the people who are
building it are making statements that
are important sometimes they're
political sometimes they're not
sometimes they're very obvious sometimes
they're hidden but like the artist is
important and there was a period in the
game industry
where
it wasn't clear
that we weren't going to be considered
like cereal in a cereal box like you
don't know who designed the cereal or
like a piece of software where you don't
know who actually made it and not like a
piece of art and during that time for
example
at uh gdc which is the game developer
conference every year
there were people that were getting
introduced for panels as you know no
name wow in your programmer publisher
wow so that you didn't know who they
were they were speaking on behalf of the
publisher mostly as a recruiting tool
but they didn't have the right to their
name
because nobody wanted the people
to to like be and it was really rough
like there were people that weren't
allowing their developers to go to gdc
it was like it was very odd and then at
the same time we were becoming a big
industry and sony was throwing parties
and microsoft was throwing parties and
others are throwing parties in hollywood
my backyard i live in l.a it's right
down the hill from where i am right now
and they weren't inviting the people who
made the games that the parties were
being thrown wow wow and
again i took it probably a little too
personally because i'd have friends
calling up and saying hey i'm going to
this party
are you going i'll see you but not are
you going i assume you're going because
someone's throwing it that you work for
are you going to be there and i'd be
like no i wasn't invited wow
they invite me as their plus one and i
was like wow there's something wrong
with this industry
speak on it and i didn't want it to head
that direction i wanted it to head in
the direction for a lot of reasons where
it is art
because when when the question is should
this game come out or should you know
video games cause violence video games
cause all of these horrible things like
art has protections
yeah other things don't like we are art
and i'm not condoning you know
everything that's ever been made but i'm
saying like
there are reasons you want to be
considered art and we are art and it was
looking really bad and so i had a voice
so again i believed
i started i got up on stage
and i wasn't afraid of failure
maybe it wasn't my brightest moment in
retrospect
but i followed my three principles and
it worked out fine it worked out yeah i
don't think
when you think about your stature at
that in the industry at that time
top of your game at naughty dog i think
the message isn't as strong if it isn't
you or someone like you it had to be you
yeah
it had to be you it had to be yeah and
other people were like i'm glad you said
that god i'm glad
because
i'm also passionate so the way i said it
going back and looking at it like
probably could have put it better
i don't know
little guy that couldn't do that that
would have got ostracized if he did
right it could have been repercussions
and you utilize your position to do
something good and that's what a leader
does yeah and it's great to see how the
industry has changed man we could talk
to you about we do have to rap
because because this is this is
phenomenal you know at some point well
jason we definitely want you to come
back and we'll definitely
doing the proper procedures do more
video stuff but um i do want to ask the
question that we do it's a tradition
here at ireland's podcast we ask every
guest in the round putting you on a spot
on this one you can answer these
which is which is
i need lord jason's top five video games
or franchises of all time oh my god this
is this one you know
i can't i can't count the number of
times i've been asked this so
the way i look at it is like this from
the beginning it's been very hard for me
to play a game and truly enjoy the game
as a as a gamer i tend to look at games
and i see the flaws and i see this
success and i see things that i've never
seen before got it there were things
ultima early on when i was playing
ultima that made me realize like where
games could go like
lord british ultima
yes
had big impacts on me
or games like doom
that you know
i remember playing that 24 hours
straight the caco demon jumped out
around the corner and i fell back in my
chair and that was the first time that i
realized that i was emotionally inside
the world as opposed to
really playing it on a screen right so
that was uh a magical moment
magic um
ultimate we said although we got ultima
those are ghosts
red dead one
like just
okay we would always do it
well you're doing so well let the man
preach about his red dead continue
it's a great game that was that was
groundbreaking um thank you
there's a moment in arizona sunshine
okay
where
i was just playing and again i'm looking
at how locomotion works and all of the
underpinnings of like you know whatever
and
this
the zombies push this bus
off a cliff
and it like falls down and in that
moment i was watching zombies push a bus
off a cliff
i was there not i was watching it on tv
but it hit me in a way
where my heart started going and like i
really felt like
i got a run because did you see how many
zom in the butt and like there was just
this thing about that that again like is
that the best game ever
i got it's not what i'm talking about
my top fives are how it affected me
whether or not it's better than two or
like two days better or whatever like
gta for whatever reason never struck me
in the same way as red dead did red dead
had the whole package was perfect and
there were moments in that where i was
like this this is so deeply art like
just and i know they're you know i'm
watching people agree and they don't
agree with whatever they agree no no
you're in the right you're not right
continue
for me as a developer those were magic
moments and i'm gonna leave the fifth
one open i'm gonna okay i'm gonna cop
out here and there we go
is that like
if i give you a fifth i will have
shorted something that ten minutes from
now i will be angry at myself for having
shortage but here's the thing you could
always come back and
realize talking 35 years 40 years of
gaming now i mean like
i'm not even going to do the math it was
85 right
83 i got my first computer
yeah you know what you do just crashing
it yeah you put crash in there
here's the thing about the games i've
made
i can't enjoy them yeah
good point
every one of them i look at and i was
like god we let that release
so we'll leave we'll leave it open for
now but uh look man we
have about
the last question i know i know he might
not answer it but i still gotta ask
we need it yep favorite
console of all time and why
he's just thinking about the consoles
he's worked on at this point
he said well the ones that i think for
me it was it was it was the playstation
it really like ps one which one which
one yes one yeah let's just go
oh my god cause before that like
the promise was there for video games
but you had to look really hard to see
it and then something about the ps1 and
the and like the the amount of memory
the cd had the the size of the games
could be the fact that it was a like
truly 3d console with like it had
horrible crashed with 3 000 polygons to
put it in perspective like i'm working
with devs now that are complaining like
about working on mobile chipsets and
stuff in headsets and their eyeballs
have more than 3 000 polygons
we made magic with those 3 000 polygons
crash was like 532 or something polygons
like he he was he was like a six of our
total polygons and most people got 2
000. we got 3 000 because we had good
coders like absolutely
but still like that that was the moment
where i was like yeah this actually is
going to be the biggest medium ever
because i could feel it like i could
actually feel it in the games and ps2
was better in ps3 is that xbox a great
console when it came out xbox like the
consoles now are wonderful and i don't i
won't say which one of the two is my
favorite because i really don't have a
favorite i like titles not hardware yeah
the playstation
one the first one of course because it
is in my heart as well yeah same thing
it was a magical moment in the in the
industry
so many rules were broken yeah not the
least of which was sony was a new
entrant into the hardware yes marketing
and yet they still
killed it yes
tremendous history the journey the
passion you're still here you still love
it we're looking forward for more in vr
the legendary jason reuben thank you
everyone of the better verse and
absolute pleasure brother thank you so
much for your time i really appreciate
it before you go waking to find people
find you what else you have going on
that you want to talk to our audience
before you leave uh i'm on twitter
he's on twitter instagram i'm on
facebook the jason rubin on facebook uh
someone got jason ruben before i did
they're at midnight when they opened it
up someone was still there before
facebook.com d jason rubin that that's
as good as anything else no doubt that's
your anywhere thank you so much for your
time real quick everybody uh said attic
kings off eddie final words lord james
before we let him have his day back
i really appreciate you coming on and uh
speaking you know a lot of a lot of the
uh past you have here you definitely is
one of the the people that we've had on
that
you've been doing this since since he
was in your teens
like i've always said like i value
passion for the gaming industry over
everything else
and like the whole time you talk and
like that's not like you are the
embodiment of passion for this industry
you always have to like i said the three
rules right believe and all that stuff
you also have to be willing to laugh at
yourself like some of the stuff that we
went through like don't take yourself
too seriously yeah no don't solve it
even final worship
thank you so much for joining us i think
for me the the great thing about having
you here is that a lot of people that
came into games when you did
burnt out and left
and art is very hard and because you
guys are sort of
you're creating you're creating the
you're creating what gaming is as it's
you know as you're going along so
the fact that you were able to sort of
survive that and and figure out what you
needed for yourself continue to be
passionate and create and then be in a
position now where you can you know the
teach the people that are coming up the
right way to do things to to to to have
a life and still be able to create these
amazing things is special because a lot
of people just walked away i can't do
this
so it's great to have you as that
example so thanks for coming on lord
appreciate any final words from the
legendary jason rubin
well one the reverence that i have for
you
uh
coming on the show and talking about a
console that i didn't have and i
pretty much had everything yeah
blew me away you made me google yeah
the fact that you made me google you put
a smile on my face my wife texts me and
said who the hell is
the fact that you made the fact that you
made him google makes me smile
you sound so happy right now and i and i
just put
he's a legend
um
i can i can i can blow vape and i can i
can go on and on but
what i what i would say is is today
you re-engineered yourself every step of
the way
every step of the way so when sovereign
said you know other people burnt out
because they didn't know how to
re-engineer their self
every time you retired
you still have a new re-engineering to
do
is this a comic book
is it a this or is it that
and you always go out on top
you know when to go just not talking
about the times i didn't i'm saying you
got to be okay listen we don't look we
we understand that
but the perception is our reality and
the perception is you're a winner
thank you absolutely but thank you so
much for gracing us today and i do
appreciate your time no doubt lord jason
was well behaved
you're good
i'm worse when i'm around my three and a
half year old than i was with you guys
this was hard i appreciate you brother
again enjoy your day thank you so much
for taking the time lord thank you jason
rubin vp of the metaverse co-founder of
naughty dog the legend enjoy your day
brother thank you so much
yeah all right please everybody share
this out this this yeah this is this is
fantastic this is amazing the creator of
crash crash bandicoot
i want to point out to the people in the
chat you know why saul gets the super
chats together like
you know if you listen to
our podcasts on like the uh the audio
the audio versions of them like uh apple
spotify like like write us man give us a
g
give us a comment you know even if it's
a back comb you don't like us you think
i laugh too much or anything like that
give us some comments man you know yes
yeah hit the review on the audio that'd
be really a price appreciate hit that
like button share it out if you can um
sorry if you need more time i can
describe enough or okay i'm
good cool
we got brickhouse arsh seven dollar
super chat i'm currently on vacation
with my wife for our one year
anniversary congratulations but i still
needed to listen to live to my favorite
podcast thank you thank you thank you
hold on break protocol shout out to the
legendary hip hop gamer iop for life
firefighter fire we outside son this
joke was good thank you brother your
inspiration brother hip hop your
inspiration brother i see you moving and
you outside and you fire crazy fire
brother some stuff man bro you i just
i'm blown away every time i see the
things you're doing but it's always an
honor to see you in the chat man one of
the og's the legendary hip-hop gamer
salute thank you for listening continue
so i just want to give hip-hop as far as
with that
there we got
family bone slave five dollar super chat
shout out to iop informative fun and
most importantly real can't wait to link
back up for e3 2023 a service server
then we got bix hutch five dollar super
chats
on the comic book exclusive talk the
world continues to sleep on the coolest
badass in all of comics blade imagine
that gameplay lords yeah we'll see
and these people are ridiculous they're
posting on twitter yeah already i got
one says la i they they're posting the
link it says lord attic laughs too much
special
wow
good
here we have ko3 black truth 20 super
chat
so dope that i lived through all of this
and get to hear the stories from the
creator of some of the my favorite games
way of the warrior was my game
i too told everyone it was better than
mortal kombat this is priceless gold
absolutely it was it tossed was
you know what kind of blows my mind the
fact that like a lot of these studios
small when they were still in their
infancy stages
like every time you hear an interview
with like someone that you know
ran studios or something they always
talk about you know our neighbor was
this the person next door was that like
a lot of these studios were literally
side by side each other earlier stages
hollywood rules 5 super chat lords what
an amazing walk through video game
history this is the content you get on
the best podcast on youtube thanks to my
four boys incredible thank you brother
appreciate that that means a lot thank
you
i've got hollywood rules once again ten
dollar super chat king great pull on the
ea yellow tab i bought the first madden
and lakers versus celtics for genesis
before they were in stores i ordered it
from ea directly from an ad in my
grandfather's movie magazine that's
crazy
we saw it me me me and cox saw it
and we like yo what they doing why they
caught cultures just looking different
everybody else was uniform but these
dudes want to be the big boy
now every time i see someone talk about
buying madden back then i'm like you the
reason my man jason couldn't sell no
more units
yeah technically it was crazy he sold
out
like he sold all his copies and they
like yeah but we're gonna go
over here god it did happen yeah because
do you think this stuff is that yeah
think about it for four reasons he still
stays at ea no yeah
and we got paris lockhart 10 super chat
key question
does jason wear crocs
here we go
oh my god good thank god we missed that
[Music]
bando cracks not blood cracks louis
vuitton i know i'm just joking
with a cup of tell fell on you you keep
this up good
we got all we got all manner of crocs we
have crash bands time
number three
there we go zero mac five dollar super
chat oh hell the iop i need lord cognito
to change that ps oculus xbox
arrangement in the background
oh you talking about xbox if you oh
y'all worried about position look the
xbox controller is on top of the
playstation logo oh my god all right
that's what it is like
it's right on top of it he said you out
of bounds
[Music]
i know i know contractors if you like
shooters so i guess is
but you stopped that that's the second
time you did that and we told you what
it was yeah oh i don't remember
moving on
[Laughter]
you gave
is the best podcast much love lord
salute
thank you
salute then we've got lord metro two
dollars to chat phenomenal interviews
thank you lord appreciate it brother
much love much love i'm
starving hold on let's take a little
break because i gotta scrap it up
all right now we got jd gamer five
dollars super chat the iop out here
having the best interviews in the
industry thank you so much
appreciate that
and we have the critical smoker
[Laughter]
i've had a console every year since
1977. facts
that profile picture finally he's been
in that profile picture for like oh yeah
then we got pixel bit g five dollar
super chat great interview lords and his
journey should remind us all that big
studios start from small beginnings
consolidation won't change that
yep well he actually said he had a
problem i mean he says but he says he
felt the way he said it is like he feels
like he's a natural person
progression he actually agreed with lord
acquisition himself
it's gonna keep going and it's gonna
keep changing and evolving that's just
what it is because there's always two
guys in the basement right now
some people want to get they joined up
have margaritas on the beach after they
work hard
so let's not act like people don't want
to sell listen after you make that
bright memory infinite you sad yeah
good to you
you brothers don't have the largest
channel but your ability to secure these
conversations with legendary figures in
the gaming space speaks to how respected
you are thank you man keep doing it your
own way bless thank you members
let it translate to cash
hit the like button any time let's share
that out yeah let's go let us grow
together let's grow together let's show
it no doubt we got over today yes sir
all right we're going to get the um i
got to describe because i did i didn't
want to do it while he was here to take
away from the time you know that time i
mean are we doing the patreon
yeah
i know but i have to describe it we need
you here for these topics yeah so look
we could cut we could cut it it's cool
we could buy it we could figure it out
look scrapbook is that time of the month
you already know what it is shout out to
the lords of gaming.net editorial team
who just kills it every bump shout out
to makboon hyundai gondor infinite ammo
flame the whole team the old squad um
look always good competition have to
give
one particular lord who went above and
beyond in the month of july he's argued
in chronicle um
actually articles are like behind the
scenes one of the most in-depth things
you can learn about this game that's
coming you know he did a yakuza like a
dragon and then obviously one of his
recent um articles about unions in
gaming the pros and cons so proudly
present the latest winner of the lord
dizzy recipes for dizzy the homie
lordsgaming.net scribe of the month
chris jones aka lord c unit he wasn't
able to be here to accept it but he left
us
a little something something for us
what's going on
it's chris jones your scribe of the
month for july aka scene cena one two
three one two three everywhere
aka the michael jordan of lognet senior
writer lords of gaming.net aka sweden
and youtube chronicles expert and uh man
i'm kind of getting those uh nicknames
like kings got huh
um i just want to say thank you and how
humbling it is to once again
be your scribe of the month every writer
for lords of gaming.net puts in their
heart and their soul every single piece
that they write
you got lord's minute so much work goes
into everything we do at lognet and it's
much appreciated the writers will be
nothing uh without the great editors
that we have so big shout out to others
mahmoud ammo flame nick
gondor josh appreciate all your work
even call get it to peace one time
um much appreciated and uh to be
associated with the lords it's a great
experience
addict king
sav cog
you guys are pillars of positivity for
the gaming community
spreading positivity in the realm
not focusing so much on the negativity
besides in the jokes
um continue to do what you guys do
and uh i will continue to be motivated
and uh sorry i can't be there um being a
part of the union keeps me away from
home
quite a bit so i don't have as much free
time as i'd like but you best believe
chris jones
we'll be back again and one day i will
be on the scribe of the month segment on
the iron lords podcast
so shout out to the iron lords the
editors the writers log net ilp
the fans we appreciate you guys so much
and we do what we do because we love to
do it
salute
to the legendary little chris jones
dropping that gem on us thank you
brother much appreciate it go hit up
solve up y'all know what it is for the
reward of the monster you know what i'm
saying but yeah again support that
larger gaming.net y'all great talent you
see what we got out here it's a lot of
things you gotta give him about his
proper name let's go let's go what we're
doing see you later
oh yeah oh he called himself a
humility
we got one more chat real quick all
right and i got the ball yeah dragon
heart yobe member for 14 months
hashtag peace love life to the legendary
iop extremely proud as always keep
laying the blueprint gents modern day
legends thank you for inspiring and
keeping up the fantastic work y'all
making grown men cry thank
thank you thank you for crying hey thank
you appreciate that
thank you for your chance i do
appreciate it cheers up you ready tears
all over the place thank you
this last week four results in the
people spoken with the recent
announcement of black panther game in
early development how confident you that
ea is backing the title i didn't know he
was doing this yes the winner of the
close three-way ilp poll at 40 of the
vote was not confident ea has a lot to
prove when it comes to single-player
focused games that are not micro
transaction heavy coming in at second
place at a 30 close 30 percent was very
confident jedi fallen order proved that
commitment to single player quality and
license ip can exist and in last place
very close at 29 of the vote was the
messi lords i don't care it's all good
and when they're making a new black
panther but i'm keeping an eye out on
what the hell is in that character
creator option salute everybody's in the
vote lord king this is your time for
dave they they feel how you felt last
week as opposed to this week
what i'm gonna say is uh
you have the right to reserve judgment
um
and
just because you know listen uh jason
showed us today you know um past
so-called
failures doesn't indicate that the
future doesn't hold something bright
i went back and i played jedi fallen
order because i had to make sure that
without my assessment of the team was
exactly what i was uh talking about and
they they earned the right for me to
reserve judgment until the game actually
shipped so i'm listen man i'm very
hopeful i'm very hopeful because there
are sparks of them keeping true to the
law so
i i i just want everybody to reserve
judgment until after the game is out
don't prejudge the game don't look for
every little screen you talk about all
his ears is wrong
exactly exactly so till then uh
oh no
yo somebody on lsm voted as a patreon it
was like something something inside
wakanda i'm like oh my god this was
somebody this is the iop and made that
day name yeah they out of pocket i see
anything
before we get into the tablet
we're good we're caught up all right
cool can you let me set you up or you
get it
because this is you all right so our
main event where a lot of people have
been waiting for oh
i think everyone can realize and know
exactly
who's talking we know whose topic this
is it says just want to be clear
um yes sony uh says it believes xbox
only call of duty could influence users
console choice so um looks like a recent
questionnaire in front of a brazilian
regulatory body um says that call of
duty is an essential game a blockbuster
a triple a type game that has no rival
and they go on to describe how much of a
powered house it is it's so powerful
that it could influence a user's console
choice and its community of loyal users
is entrenched enough that even if a
competitor had the budget to deliver a
similar product it would not be able to
rival it they go on to talk about the
resources that call of duty has and
about the development teams they talk
about um you know again
recruiting and what they how to expect
it to be even more successful in the
future no other game developer can
develop the same level of resources and
expertise in game development and they
said it's been call of duty has been a
top selling game it's overwhelmingly the
best game it's synonymous with
first-person shooters it defies the
category and they said it added to say
the least players were unlikely to
switch to an alternative game as they
would lose their familiality those
skills and even the friends they made
playing call of duty games so saudi had
a lot of things to say
about
this uh the impact of call of duty so
king this is your topic man
do do you what do you feel about these
statements
sony out here
they shooting oh major look there you go
your page in my rhymebook
yo why are y'all doing this why are you
going out this side why are you gonna go
in front of the brazilians and be like
let me tell you man
we ain't got nothing that can compete
with that
uh you're talking from experience you're
talking from what you did to us you're
talking for what happened from the 360
era when we had the marketing rights the
call of duty and every casual was like
you know the xbox boxes the box
and then y'all got the marketing rights
for the playstation 4.
y'all was 100 cheaper
and y'all realize that's how
360 won that battle
you know the power of call of duty yeah
so when y'all was like oh they brought
who
oh shorty charlie i'm talking to nah not
shorty oh come on not not that bad chick
from 35th oh god please not her i like
her she bring everybody around the club
stay packed because shorty be in there
now shorty ain't gonna be in your club
like that you hurt
you good yo when you found out she got
booked to another club and it's
exclusive over there you dudes is like
oh not shorty
you don't care about they say number
diablo
they didn't say nothing about any other
title they single-handedly pointed out
one title because they knew they knew
exactly who is the ball of chick and who
gonna bring all the boys to the yard
the kalisto is the khalifa
[Laughter]
yo i know
they trying to do anything now right now
they why are you gonna go for the
brazilian
yo let me tell you something what
they're doing over there man
you try to imply like they tell it like
they did not because you know why
everybody got the question there mm-hmm
and only these dudes
you just got bungee
you're gonna tell me that you don't got
a first person studio i mean uh a first
uh first party studio that can't make
games of the caliber or call of duty so
what you just said was
you knew bungie for the streets
you just looked at it and was like you
hot though but you ain't called a dirty
guy like you are right but you ain't all
right so you knew your
your purpose in that purchase
was a reflex
you tried to stunt
i got shorty too like i got a shirt are
you implying
bungie's a rebound relationship
afterwards
when you're trying to stop the wedding
anyone objects to this wedding you the
dude raising your hand put your hand
down and go sit down stop trying to stop
this from happening and i understand
it's gonna hurt you
but this is good for you though
you've been playing these tactics
you've been doing these things
i still ain't got final fantasy yet so
don't think i hear your cries and i'm
out here like oh
bandito
no man let it burn
let it burn
yeah but we got god of war sony told you
anything we making ain't messing with
you
they said there's unrivalled chamber
nothing we nothing we come up with you
know how are you going
we can't conceive of anything that can
that can mess with these dudes you have
folded your tent and went home you took
your ball and went home because once
this deal go down you already know
competition
i'm gonna sit here and i'm gonna just
sit here and eat and enjoy king's
drinking i i really i really love these
moments because it seems like this sony
ain't the jason sony oh
this sony ain't the aggressive sony like
what the dale oatmeal we out here let's
go we got stuff on deck we're ready to
fight when halo came out y'all made kill
zone oh
they they always had an issue
this this sony right here they snitching
they point people out
i will say this they literally first off
i don't even know why they went to the
like i can understand publishers but to
go to sony the person that's literally
dating the
the head marketing thing that they have
that's literally depending on that call
of duty reference that they have the
marketing they have a partnership with
them to go and be like how do you feel
about about them buying that company
that'll make sense to me
so they are low keep like well
you know well it's brazilian regulating
fairness they have to by law and no
fairness well they have to respond by
law it's like it's repeated like you got
to come to court now it stands to reason
that this messaging is
uniform across sony i would think yes
unless you know they're just letting the
they know it's just from wow [ __ ] sony
brazil run wow let's say whatever they
want to say
right because like king said everyone
was asked right and like attic was said
then now it's on them to say
it's not in their best interest to
say what's good that is because this is
going to be good for interest not good
necessarily for them particularly so
good at it i was going to say i'm sorry
i think you know i want to clear
something up people are like
i do think people are obviously king
will be king but i do think people are
blowing this out of proportion i don't
think they mean call of duty
they can't replicate that i think they
mean we could never make a brand like
call of duty it's not that they can make
i o i would argue destiny is just as a
caliber as a game as call of duty but
it's brand wise
call of duty just completely tanks over
uh call of duty they say destiny they
said noella developer can devote the
same level of resource they said even if
they could call of duty is overly overly
entrenched so that no rival no matter
how relevant they are can catch up they
they basically say it's it's impossible
to be like yeah i mean that's literally
what they they're implying so no it's
interesting i want in finnish i want to
say like microsoft had a statement kind
of replying that to um that's cute
he looked over it was like oh you're
snitching huh
but microsoft wasn't exactly out of it
oh it is they said yes specifically with
respect to activision blizzard video
games there is nothing unique about the
video games developed and published by
activision blizzard that is a must-have
cover that is a must-have for rival
nothing unique about from rival pc
console to game displays this is what
they read in response to the new zealand
commission
this is how they downplayed it like it's
not even that like if you look at it
like
i think they're taking the as far as
special gameplay to like the other kind
of game
but as far as as far as like brand wise
like i think that's the thing like
sony was talking about the icon call of
duty not individual games the icon known
as call of duty nah let me give you the
google translate the translation
microsoft was like yeah shawty i man why
you tripping
why is that good
it sucks
[Music]
big pulling bad shorties why are you
tripping now
[Laughter]
absolutely hilarious
yes i mean this is
this is definitely the okay king i'm
sorry i love you i just i just love i
just love this you you i can't write a
better script you guys have released me
like you don't understand like
they okay
my
other three
co-hosts
literally laugh when i put stuff in chat
and say this is my topic
and i tell them every week
i have faith in the gods that sony gonna
do something stupid
how stupid is this you what that was a
bait trap that was a trap
hit
[Laughter]
that's exactly what the brazilians said
they gave you
they served it to you on the planet they
knew they shouldn't ask you that
question and they slid it to you and
they you triggered their trap card and
look at you now look at you your fan
base is like not like this sony not like
this don't tell them you scared what the
hell you gonna say
yo come outside man we fighting do i
really gotta go
it ain't like anything i do is gonna
make a difference
are you scared to fight yo what type of
sony this isn't this see this see guys
this is why i love phil dominance
maximus really is spencer
he ain't scared to fight
he ain't scared so when he when he was
fighting with bare knuckles when he was
fighting with bare knuckles with y'all
in the street and y'all sitting him in
the head with bricks and y'all was doing
all this crazy stuff
and then satya looked over and was like
yo that who that warrior down there
okay so that young warrior there yo
everybody bail that up let's go let's
surround this dude
we gonna rock with this dude right here
og came down off the hill now you're
running scared the whole team come out
and every week they're acquiring new
dudes so you see the army getting bigger
so when y'all squabbling with young phil
now young phil squad will get crazy now
y'all don't want them knuckle games no
more the other one how the hell a whole
company gonna say we can't make nothing
to compete
i don't care what nobody's saying i mean
don't verbalize your skin
here's the thing
they're not wrong like they they they
can never replicate what call of duty
has done they can't ever there's very
few brands
they can't even remotely touch call of
duty how do you think microsoft owns a
brand that comes closer that may be
minecraft minecraft they own it now
when your knuckle game ain't right you
buy mike tyson
[Laughter]
they got young mike in his prime yo on
god
i i don't think i can write a better
script
and i love you guys because you know
what happened
can you hear can you hear it now
do it you triggered my trap card yeah i
was perfect
the ham hockey eating dudes that was
sitting there talking all that shrapnel
remember you yo you remember when i
first when i popped on the scene for
twitter you don't remember
your xbox ain't got no games based
hey i a one no no you're like king you
gotta you you gotta be pilling it with
with uh
this this right here is a ham hock being
that on him yeah
yo
listen young and sit down man i'll show
you how these game things work you know
sony always going to be the best
triple a bangers the triple a baggage
aaa bang
yo when your own company say we ain't
got triple a bangers that can mess with
that dude
i've never heard this from a competitive
company it's like equivalent to like you
you you you're working your way up on
something and they're like yo we good
man we good they we if we good as long
as they don't oh they did it nevermind
[Laughter]
settled and you've seen both sony
statements as far as the influence
nothing they feel kind of arrival at
their backs like
it's no big deal it's just no it's
definitely a big
you know they could say whatever it's
like i said like i don't think sony was
talking about like
even like any individual game or you
know the black ops franchise or anything
like that i think sony's like look this
goes beyond gaming call of duty whoever
owns that marketing rights i mean you
can argue whoever is on the call of duty
marketing rights has won every
generation you can
that's a great argument
so it's just like you know the 360 had
it people could sit there and say you
know the playstation caught up after
after the race was over which makes no
sense once you pass the the the finish
line and you into a new generation
people's like but sony caught up and
passed yeah because microsoft wasn't
running anymore
so it's just like look like that is big
you can argue that call of duty the
marketing just marketing
the ps5 or xbox series snx at the end of
that commercial is more important than
the actual game because the games are
subjected they go up and down multiple
studios making them they're not always
on par with what you would expect from a
call of duty but to be able to come out
there on that super bowl sunday and have
a commercial that says call of duty on
xbox and imagine that i think the people
think it's bad now imagine when you see
these super bowl commercials and they
say day one on game pass
people like oh what's game pass oh oh
and then not to mention they'll probably
mark it towards a casual audience like
that with the series
promo pick up a series s for three
hundred dollars and leave with call of
duty imagine
they dropped the price to 200 on some
christmas two hundred
with three months of game passing with
the custom
skin
you see they got the four guys one they
got a custom
cards console with little man on it and
you run out
and i think that
uh pl microsoft's statement was the
exact opposite uh adjacent that they did
they're like look
we do we will probably end up getting
call of duty if this deal goes through
but it's just like besides brand
recognition recognition what else does
cod really provide that has up and down
values in terms of what the games
provide to what's it has multiple
studios making it like besides that
brian recognition which is everything
is it really special to compare to a
destiny compared to these other type of
games because with those other games you
get consistent content with those other
games with call of duty goes up and down
now you know when you put that brand
recognition in with it
sony's 100 right they scared they run
and they like we we we need new
management that's
it's like it's just like they can't
replicate that and i think that
they're trying with this free to play
market and they're just like
to have someone like microsoft able to
come out there and constantly be
promoting call of duty people don't
realize how much brand
impressions uh
no brand recognition uh uh
when you when you put your brand on
someone else's brand oh i know what you
uh
how it how you put your brand on someone
else's brand so it's like brand
recognition yeah no it's it's pretty
much like it diminishes the brand you
mean no like okay brand association
brand association yeah you see call of
duty on there for all ps4 generation you
saw call of duty and playstation side by
side for the majority of that generation
yeah so when you're seeing this over and
over again
it's tricking the minor to thinking yo i
gotta get a playstation to play that
game then you look at some i mean you
you take a psych uh
uh you know take it a little bit further
with psychology like there's a reason
people end up putting like cigarettes
with with drinking coffee because
they're they're linking those two
together and people like yo i can't i
can't drink coffee without cigarettes so
it's just like you have that same thing
where it's like
no but you you get what i'm saying i
don't know
when people connect two things together
it's hard to do one without the other no
i understand that's the way the casual
mind works they don't know this industry
like that they just they buy the console
and play the game and when they're going
on there and they've seen on super bowl
sunday where it's like yo
we got this thing called a playstation 4
free and this new game called black ops
3's out with it like yo let me go and
get a playstation play this call of duty
game like that's all they see no it's a
good one that's the reason the majority
that's the reason you see people
fighting over the 2k license people
fighting over the fifa license people
fighting over the call of duty license
they fight for these license because
these marketing rights because they know
whoever owns the majority of these
especially call of duty you can win an
entire generation just off call of duty
you only need the rest you just need
call of duty
and when you win this generation it
might be curtains for that other dude
it's a good point because you know
i know you know the hardcore we as the
hardcore don't want to hear this but the
reality is the casuals drive the game
industry and and what attic is saying in
reference to brand association is true
because the casual is not listening to a
podcast most of the time kaiser's not
you know paying attention to all the
news bits and what's going on industry
casual walk in the store and if they see
the game that is the hottest game
associated with a console whether it be
marketing or what have you then that
makes them think that you can't get it
anywhere else you can only get it here
and that's that new generation of um of
gamer and i i totally understand where
you're coming from if you said i was
going to get uh solved in and see what
he he thought about all of this
so what i find interesting is that
despite phil saying hey i you know call
of duty isn't going anywhere
you're going to honor the contract
though right yeah he's going on the
contract right despite that being said
you know
given the opportunity they're going to
derail this they're going to derail this
acquisition
possible they don't care if that like if
it was exclusive that would hurt but
that's taking it off of their
perspective at that point they know that
the majority of the people buying their
playstations right now when it was the
ps4 generation it was that casual
consumer and when they keep losing those
lego blocks to build that castle
eventually that capsicum falls
that is correct so so this is the thing
right
so
when you look at it that way thoughts
are crazy today yeah yeah when you look
at it that way
is there an indication right that they
whatever they still have a deal they
still have a deal that deal is not
infinite there is a fight there's
finality to that deal at which point you
have to renegotiate right 2024.
so
this comes off as this comes off as that
when the current deal that's in place
goes away
our leverage for what we'll be able to
get in terms of call of duty changes yes
and it could change and the language out
there is vague enough yes
that that change could amount to
core call of duty games not coming to
playstation right right way way solve
right
it could because if you turn and call it
first of all call of duty stops being
annualized right and you turn it into an
every two or three year thing you get
call of duty right
then then it's
it's sort of positioned as this
juggernut that comes out every year and
dominates changes now
microsoft would not be reneging on what
they said
if they do that and warzone still
continues to grow and be what it is
if they flip the
i i think that you're on to something
when it comes to certain scenarios but i
don't think they're going to do with the
main core series i think once these
deals are up if they rebring back like a
like a black ops trilogy or something
right they br they refresh them remake
them bring them back as a collection i
think they might hold those on their
consoles in this console exclusive but
as far as like the main driving force
known as call of duty like the the
everyday i don't know what they're going
to do every year or every other year but
i do feel like people have this
conception that like if microsoft gets
approved for buying activision that
they're automatically to go and they're
going to be like look
yeah we uh you guys you guys aren't
making call of duty none of you are like
right no i i think you got might get
like toys for box might come off of it
and they might go back to like the crash
franchise or maybe right even make like
a conqueror or something like that but
as far as that i think the majority of
those studios mostly still continue to
make call of duty yeah for sure i don't
know that you stop the gravy training
right you figure out better ways to do
it like you said move people around
necessarily not necessarily make it a
yearly thing and not
do everything you can to not have it
stagnate right
and and i'm playing devil's advocate
because i firmly i do believe that call
of duty it's just a smart thing call of
duty is that you know and their argument
holds water where it's like it's so big
pause that um
that it's something that whoever holds
that ship whoever holds that ring of
power controls the world and
the the difference here five rings that
what's his name has in that marvel
exactly the mandarin
it's like call of duty's one of them
minecraft's one of them fortnite's one
of them and like and like they're going
there like we want all exactly we
already got minecraft years ago for the
cheap cheap if you really think about it
now we're gonna walk up here and knock
on activision to get that second rate
and then
but we ain't never probably gonna get
fortnight but that's okay because we got
more rings then we could you know i
think the funniest thing about all this
right it's because it's microsoft right
and it's their first party competitor
because if another third-party publisher
came and scooped up activision blizzard
no one would be arguing there would be
no no it's fine you know what you yeah
but you know everybody still gets it but
it's microsoft
let me tell you why
they're crying wow
cause it's the last damn place
here we go
here we go this was cemented sony sony
came out and said it they said if
man if we we can't win we can't win
we can't win remember
for that man you know what's funny they
say and it's true it makes them right
it's like they they're they're playing
the victim here like oh my god always be
like what's gonna happen to us and if
you allow this to happen but
that's what you're supposed to say
though you're supposed to be like yo
it's not good for the same way [ __ ]
won't be like nah
they don't make nothing hot there is
nothing
intentional they see the beef happen and
they getting jumped and they looking to
the teacher you ain't gonna stop
king the funny part is the other bully
you're the bully you know what they
remind me of doing all this and he came
from around that desk and punched you in
your mouth and you looked over at the
teacher and said you ain't gonna stop
when you have like
animals and they're sitting there
fighting and you have that cat that just
looks at the owner like can you stop him
the [ __ ] part i was saying
you want some of this
and this dude said wait a second you
ain't going to stop me
excuse me brazil you know whatever what
do you think is like even if he is what
do you think is that you even the
general nintendo has those stake in call
of duty so it doesn't matter it's cool
whatever they can do whatever they want
we doing our own thing so it's only
playstation that's this is crying about
it's just funny to see kind of a little
bit of comfortable because they know
what i did yeah it's like you know what
you did to win a generation
i know what you did you know what's
funny
yeah xbox said what you said xbox was
like yo but did y'all what did y'all
keep the final fantasy off all platforms
don't y'all have spider-man don't you
have god of water that draw drives all
this you know exclusive content to your
yeah but the argument is the purity of
it because those are you know
those are ingrown these though
it was homegrown
you built those up beside me you didn't
buy insomniac insomniac brought us
that that's how the industry works it's
like it does feel like especially when
it comes to you know timed exclusivity
because i've always said you get the
right time to exclusivity that
yeah that's more that's definitely start
with that time exclusivity with this
final fantasy man it's more than that
yeah no no you're playing dirty tactics
you're playing games yeah
you're taking what i'm saying you're
blowing out before no no no no i'm i'm
being a joke right now this is the joke
the joke is you want those dirt at
people you can't say how he reacts to
what you did
you can't you can't say that that's what
i've been saying for the longest that's
what i'm saying like yeah you have
people like me that aren't getting the
final fantasy 7's the free birds uh it
doesn't look like tactics ogre's coming
to the platform and that's another
type of game so it's just like you look
at stuff like that and it's just like
i get it people are upset you know call
of duty most likely a lot of the
marketing probably uh you know a month
of exclusivity on some of the dlc you
probably have some like
some form of exclusivity in terms of
content on warzone people like that's
not right you know what's not right the
fact that these games were multiplied
for like 10 years all on exclusive to a
platform that they weren't multi-player
it's not like sony owns these studios
they don't yeah so it's just tactics in
the background yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying and but money happens
in the beginning
dudes was happy
of how stuff was going yeah wow talking
down on microsoft like you got all this
money you this big entity how come you
ain't doing it
how come you ain't doing it they used to
say that all the
i had a whole conversation you got all
this money yeah and they don't they
treating you like second second
second-class citizens that's what it is
we get treated what was it the verbiage
was we over here at places get treated
like first-class citizens and they're
investing so it's okay to money and buy
exclusive content and keep it off your
platform because they care about us they
care about why don't you if xbox was
serious about gaming why don't they
spend the money until you're probably
interrupting but to your point i got it
i gotta ride with you on this one
because it's like what's that expression
you can't control how somebody react if
you bully someone and smack someone in
the face and he come back down the
street with the gun and shoot you that's
on you because you've been bullied
so now they're utilizing the war chest
that they have and then it's like oh not
like this no i didn't think
not like no it didn't go like this
into a snap fight
microsoft went home came back and
they're like all right you bullied me
for a couple years now i'm buying your
house yeah but now
i'm buying your friend's house i'm
buying your dad's house
i don't really listen i know this is a
legal thing and i want to be clear i
want to give the context so shout out to
my boy ben smith we had a good
conversation from last time meeting
behind the scenes and i wanted the
context is yes they have to sony has to
respond right it's like you almost think
of subpoena what do you think about it
you got to talk about it and i get it
you got to protect your business all i'm
saying is
[Music]
sony might not have the whole six nine
but they have like half
how do you feel about them it's like sir
i don't like this at all
i think they're taking all of our toys
away from us what he said was do you see
the perpetrator in question today and he
said yeah he right there
who
you know you can go to other friends
there's no friend like
all i was saying if that's the [ __ ]
and everybody was sitting there it was
like and you
did
heard
this
the witness to the court
and everybody looking at sony woke up
like what i know they didn't yo so
everybody played it cool my boss was
sitting there they was like yo so call
of duty going over there how you feel ea
was like it's no sweat off my back
they actually ubisoft was like man we
don't worry about those dudes we got our
own thing that's nintendo nintendo said
let me tell you okay
wait wait wait wait wait these premium
balls i can't get this
they can't get this team right here so
we don't care about what call of duty
does and that division does
and they asked sony sony was like but
i'm gonna tell you man
last time
after the activision thing was done and
imagine like conversation in the
background like somebody's talking to
ubisoft man i think microsoft's about to
buy activision and that you'd be like a
word how much are they gonna buy them
for i'm hearing rumors like 70 bills oh
really and he's like you think they'd
buy us
is that the thing that i think is being
missed too is i know king's going on his
scared snitching route i know when you
do it but i think what's interesting
what is
yo besides the call of duty concerned
right they didn't talk about anything
else they no they actually
showed how much they were concerned
about game pass that part because they
said game pass said they got gun
[Laughter]
so they said the thing they said in that
document where they expressed the
concerns about what do they say oh my
god hold on
for megatron sodium acting like a
character oh y'all messy yeah y'all
messy i do i do what y'all do y'all got
to behave oh
shout out to the mega job bring the doll
where did microsoft touch you listen
you're messy all i'm gonna say is that
in that document though he said
according to them game pass manages to
capture 60 to 70 of the global
subscription services market and about
70 or 80 in brazil when it comes to um
pc subscriptions and they said they talk
about this part of the story so they
also explained that gay pass had 10
million at uh subscribers after the time
of zmax but that's the deal but they
said this number of subscribers
increased to 25 million as soon as you
know as far as the activision
announcement so basically what their
concern is they're saying because of
game pad that that's actually thing that
concerned about getting into the other
quarters
so they like the secrets so they said
because of game pass they're looking at
it like well it's going to hurt us
because we got a 70 version that they
could put in their service you know what
i'm saying so that's the point i think a
lot of people besides the brand
recognition the marketing rights and all
the other stuff that it's associated
with the fact that this could
potentially be a gay past day and date
to their seventy dollar version of
getting of call of duty because let's be
clear the thing to song's point
i was a little weirded out like why are
you
so upset because it's not like
it's not like you're not you're gonna
lose it you're gonna have it on
playstation platform but the thing
they're saying is yo it's not i don't
it's not entirely not true though you
know what it is
when you see game pass version day and
day of call of duty and the casual and
then you have the marketing on top of
that and then we talked about a little
man and 200 and all these things that
could potentially happen and we just had
you know lord justin on from esports
call of duty esports league is crazy
a lot of people don't put a lot of like
a lot of energy behind overwatch but
that's a big brand too yeah
but that's not what this stitching is
about you know what's funny king it's
like it's like it's like they went and
they asked
you know sony and sony just started
snitching on the whole family
the wife did this the father knows his
game passes running around like i can't
keep nothing
lawyers lawyers have to present he said
yo let me tell you something about these
dudes man
we got this game pass thing and
70 of the crowd they just
i was laughing at them i thought it was
unsustainable but obviously they
sustained it
and then they got this cloud thing
did i did y'all ask me about cloud oh no
not yet
so
you replied they're telling all the
business they snitching on the whole
organization they said well listen this
is where he goes this is how it goes
this is what's gonna happen too after
all that was made and they went home and
everything was settling down
and you're just sitting there in the and
the people get a phone call and they're
like oh it's sewing they pick up like oh
now they got a family pass please oh i
forgot about the family fast let me tell
you something i'm gonna pull up in front
of sony uh
the big building you know how you you go
with those big giant inflatable rats
oh no yo
[Music]
[Laughter]
writing we don't care
how you gonna be part of that situation
don't don't ever come at me talk about
your rep the situation
over there
you are not from the block you are
ostracized right now
i can't even look at my playstation
[Music]
i go inside the room my playstation got
on a mustache isn't witness potential oh
man what is going on over there who's in
charge because this ain't the sony i
know see he's in witness protection
[Music]
you know when they have the video and
they show the guy in the silhouette yeah
microsoft has all game pass and all
i don't think they should borrow call of
duty because it hurts not the silhouette
king not the faceless shadowy figure
with the voice
yo they like this hey so tell us
everything
tell the insider everything man
well basically what they do around three
o'clock
and the retention rate is crazy
do you feel threatened by that king we
just launched a new service and we still
can't compete
you know it's kind of crazy they didn't
say they did say nothing they could do
would be able to compete with gabe but
that was gonna work
king what what what do you want what do
you want the insider to do that i want
to want somebody to stop them nobody's
going to stop
why is there nobody stopping this well
king if you send the insights to please
send the insider 50 000 in paypal maybe
i'll move a little bit listen we don't
paid all the appropriate places and
nobody seems to be stopping this fight
king you paid everybody but me
listen
where can i cash out for you
do i need to go to brazil and complain
give me the proper route to complain
oh this is the best i don't care what
y'all say y'all part of that
organization now i got the
there you have it the king's assessment
of
of how this deal worked clearly i think
being some of the only two that think
that they were ordered to respond legal
response
i do think it was a legal thing it was
just jokes
like at the end they like i don't care
like
it's like
okay
you know it's it's like the whole thing
with microsoft they lay they made their
bed yeah and they had to catch
you put all of this energy behind call
of duty and now that it's been bought up
you didn't buy it if you made it because
you didn't buy it because someone else
is buying yeah what it is to me is it
it's a lack of foresight on the subsides
of some instances because the way i look
at it is
they are the king of the just one
narrative experience right that that
movie level experience right but we've
already like we just need just one game
to
play but we've we've always said that
it's the casual that moves the
the audience the the zeitgeist the call
of duty's the gta's the the maddens the
the 2ks all these games that hardcore
gamers don't really care for if you look
at the engagement these are the games
that move the industry called call of
duty is clearly that what i think the
foresight lack that's just my opinion is
that even though as great as the games
that they make right what they did was
they used the third-party marketing
deals and said you know what let's clear
up our deficiencies with that so we
don't have to necessarily we won't make
them ourselves and they did that too
right and they did right so now they
looked at what 360 then maybe on some
level say look they had that marketing
right when that deal goes up we have to
get which was smart i felt with them
taking the playstation the call of duty
marketing rights so now when this they
have debug rights they think they're
good they hear this announcement because
let's be clear so if kings defend now
this is the part i will say is scare
talk to me because when the announcement
first
all of this brazilian regulated stuff
out of nowhere so he's like yo i hope
you guys are going to honor the the
contracts of of of of of call of duty
where it's going to be and i did was
stuttering just like that and then phil
had to make the statement and
preemptively say because it's
microsoft's best interest for the deal
to go through and not get attention to
them with the ftc so in my opinion they
probably made the concession look let's
make this thing multi-plat we don't want
the heat we want this deal to go through
right and now with sony this is my only
thing is that
when now
it's setting in right at 2024 whatever
the marketing right is over acceptance a
game pass is allowed to say day and date
this is uh over here right
now you look at your multiplayer live
service offerings right and you see the
deficiency but what i say to it is
you look at the bungee deal right
you just countered that you just said
okay we we have to have something my own
now it makes sense why the budget deal
happened after the announcement so
that's you sure enough trying to show up
your weaknesses now you're saying 10
live service games and things of that
nature that's what i think is going on
here me personally i don't have a
problem with the competing you know i'm
saying like i i've always said as much
as i give xbox yo where's your hashtag
just one bro where is it at i always say
the place say yo where's your
multiplayer you guys didn't resist this
you guys did so-called like what's going
on there i want them both to get better
so my thing is this is gonna have to
light a fire
to get your multi-player your live
service in order and i don't have no
problem with it you know so it's just
funny to me to see how this thing play
out but that's how i look at it all
right
i don't beat this dead horse yeah
yep i'm good i love everybody else we
can move oh i thought it was interesting
good job super chat sir we have already
while he doing that i can get back into
the mix
[Music]
sonny was like call of duty's being
bought go go spin ben studios budget go
buy bungie like yeah
okay
yo we gonna squabble he said no i don't
want no more squabbles
[Laughter]
they're in there for a long time
sony and microsoft in there for a
long-term boxing match and microsoft got
them against the rubs like stop it
stop squabbling me
look over here
please separate us
oh my god oh my gosh
all right ready let's go let's go let's
go
we got
mandigo mcfickins 20 super chat the
ponies have been buried how can any pony
utter a word after those statements by
jim dance move right it wasn't jim dan
i lied and swindled you i'm not
committed to you game pass can't be
matched we need call of duty ryan
playstation is what it's something is
cat poop it looks like
oh my god
disclaimer these are not the thoughts
he's super chat
now we got the taco bell for 15 months
i love how king talking about the same
topic on boom show is so different than
him on iop
hey you behaved on boom show
no i call them rats
tell me how bad
hey sony ever heard of the pot and the
tea kettle oh my god
[Laughter]
to the brazilians they can still get
some cod warzone maybe
the overcharging sony for what they did
to the code
[Laughter]
well one thing we forgot about is that
revenue too that microsoft style is
gonna get you know that sony not gonna
get any revenue
[Laughter]
they said nothing about king the money
maker for real for real
right now they don't care about king
yeah that's true well king is that's
that's
all the
you better money out for me
what you gonna do when you see me
i can't i can't live
then we got jd game with twenty dollars
we chat sony out here scared as hell
confident men like companies slash
companies don't talk about how no matter
how many little blue pills they take
games they make yo
they'll never measure up you're okay but
if men companies pull up pull out and
perform yeah
i could give you the best tv show ever
it's called scared and snitching
wow yeah i'm messing with this wow
then we got remedy live four pound and
forty nine pence super chat sony to the
hardcore gamers you ain't enough sony to
their studios you ain't got the skills
that matter yeah yo they go it is
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh my god then we got man dingo bigfoot
what's he doing
can someone tell chris
blue oyster heart that sony can't pull
mob or destiny why because they have
some success and they do not have the
authority to pull them sony and mlb got
sony but bungie and mlb got sony by the
cojones
the cojones you know chris might be
right though man chris might be right
i call him blue oyster heart sure
i just think it's not in the bench best
interest for sony i mean for xbox to
pull call of duty from playstation no
and it's not our best interest for sony
to pull on bungie's dusty stuff from
xbox because
the regulators are on these guys and at
the end of the day if you start doing
these bad faith things you trying to
make other future deals
it ain't gonna happen because look at
that
bungie first of all told you in the
beginning you ain't telling me what i'm
doing you understand like
at the prenup there's no prenup you i'm
not signing that paper i'm doing what i
want to do i'm going to see who i want
to see because i really like feeling
them
i see you on monday i'm going out it's
friday
there we go flame two dollar super chat
i completely agree with xbox caller with
xbox call of duty as trash oh my god
i actually had to play messi
then we got abba cab 72 member for 19
months to be fair uh activision blizzard
king went to microsoft to be bought and
microsoft wasn't even their first choice
microsoft was the first to say yes
end of the day doesn't matter they
bought them and that's it like
they got hollywood rules your man stop
snitching
are you mad and watch keep my company
yo
yo
hollywood rules five dollars
laura [ __ ] throws the best alien game
are you implying sir
magic johnson a podcast i just let king
work man i got the best podcast panel
period like i let y'all work
does tag teams
solve with me we hear we're the straight
man like
joy you go it's nothing
then we got lord metro at five dollars
for chat sony crying meanwhile at
nintendo headquarters private vip room
ted dibiase he crashes the party yo
nintendo money money money money
[Music]
remember that
let me say this clearly sony is scared
and there's nothing that their fans can
do to say otherwise because sony said it
themselves now who does that
right the papers weren't supposed to go
out those are sealed documents
then
then we got k johnson member for seven
months thank you man thank you
bungie looking at sony after their cod
statement am i a joke to you
right now
bunji is just mr right now
wow fun bungie is for streets
and soon he knows it
then we got a taco ten dollars in a chat
somebody literally doesn't have an
argument to say that cod will be
detrimental to their business because
the switch is outselling both consoles
without god how they gonna explain that
yeah he's right i mean listen yo stop
talking about me don't bring me inside
none of this don't bring me the
accomplishments this is for the
regulators and people the regulators as
much as sony whoever compared like
they're looking at what's best for the
gamer and the consumer
having it on a game pass service is best
for the consumer so it's going to be
hard for them to win that argument
they're not going to win by snitching
sit down shut up and take your lumps
he gave him five dollars super chat sony
running scared reminds me of that moment
in friday when smokey was standing over
devo saying you gotta knock the f out
not like this
smack somebody for a generation don't
get mad somebody come back
tell them sit down and shut up take your
lumps
then we got to give her a gay five
dollar super chat michael solved this
craig and he was taking debo ish early
on and then sadia hyped him up and not
and not devo on the ground getting
robbed after getting knocked out
knocked out
of the brick
[Laughter]
[Music]
with the brick
yo shout out to my man harry cuts he
bought that classic iopt of black
salutes you harry cuts you already don't
got that jesus that's funny absolutely
the fact that it's craig
and craig face was using halo that's
right
there we have dad lazaro five dollars if
we check when godzilla put his foot on
kong's chest that's xbox and playstation
right now god is a checkmate he's just
sitting on this stuff fighting
[Laughter]
shut up five bernie
[Laughter]
get him he's trying to drown me
somebody's true ain't nobody going to
stop this
stupid tony it's king kong
okay
we got jd gamer 10 super chat microsoft
doesn't need to bake cottage exclusive
to put sony in the ground all they need
to do with what sony did somebody
provided the blueprint just follow it
exclusive card content betas and time
content rest in peace playstation jesus
it ain't no playstation 6 around here
snitching like that going on once the
hood finds out that you were snitching
it's over for you you're finishing it's
curtains time
then we got fixed with [ __ ] which are
the
[Music]
xbox the playstation snitches get
stitches
letters
this game called an xbox podcast yeah
let's not make one brand associated with
negative connotations
best podcast in the world
[Laughter]
no doubt splendiferous
sony we can't let y'all buy activision
son xbox y'all bought bungie sony oh
that was different i can't let you body
my console with one purchase yo
crazy
it's a lot of scripts coming you know
falling out of here what's going on
we got jd gamer five dollars i want
[Laughter]
gotta put the foot down
[Music]
then we got yeah baby five out of five
dollar super jack
so the exec's gonna wake up with a horse
head next to him in the bed for being
stool pigeons
yeah they're taking this ratting thing
oh god
big time
oh no that's so good
then we got jd gave a five dollar super
chat somebody stopped it somebody
stopped this beat down diva was begging
for me to help please help him or you
could just rob him while he's laying
there wow
about it later
savage
and we got necromancer sale 10 super
chat cog and song who are you putting
your tips on for winning this this
generation based off of what we know
right now microsoft or sony no offense
city oh cause we sit under we do we
don't speak facts oh that's what that's
why he directed that towards you guys
they told they told me there was nothing
that xbox could do in this generation
competition wants to know who you
think's what
every generation is completely funny so
you know you know what's funny
hold on
i gotta call cong out a little bit okay
i
do we not have chat guests all the time
or calls like you got to choose between
the children
all right but the question all right the
question is mad general when how when
what
i assume but what what what does that
quantify if you're talking about
hardware sales i don't know but if
you're talking about
you know who wins the zeitgeist and
cloud and and game pass as a service
then i think microsoft is better
positioned
if
cog says he thinks that going beats
playstation again but what's the
specific question who's going to win is
so general like if everyone isn't over
yet the deal isn't sale yeah when the
deal is sealed so is their fate
just keep playing this baby pool man
gabe is winning that's it gabe gabe
winner
generation
you know what my ass my bad take that
back i'll take that back switch
all i'm saying is you could play the
games from all of those platforms on one
other platform
how about your legal message
leave that over here microsoft too be
quiet continue
there we go
go ahead daddy i was like i just noticed
you you misspelled our next topic and
people in the chat are pretty yeah
sony's next move is to be a third-party
publisher now i'm done with you chris
just like playstation has done
chris you've gotta be out here repping
these rats you're better than that
listen stop associating yourself with
those dudes what's
[Music]
i don't know what you're talking about
he's like i ain't changing it now i
don't know what's going on i mean maybe
it's possible okay okay i guess we just
go say like we we we looked at it wrong
man you know what i looked at it wrong
it was the angles the eggs
caught in the brazilian alley sony pull
your pants up and get that cream off
your face whoa embarrassing yourself
whoa
what is going on in this alley there's a
lot of scenarios
i get that scenario but
yeah
wow whoa
[Laughter]
very vivid vivid imagination that's kind
of crazy
we got jd gabriel again
we know how this ends sony's standing
next to blockbuster in the afterlife
saying who did it to you blockbuster
says netflix and sony's is damn you
think microsoft is buying that too
in heaven
playstation is certainly gonna walk past
blockbuster like who did it to you he's
like i'm not talking i'm not talking
get away from me yeah
he's over the top
that's even worse they walk by
blockbuster and but
they try to be friendly with blockbuster
i remember you he's like we don't
associate with rats
wow
everybody else said come over here
blockbuster get away from that
the playstation 6 walking around heaven
god why did you let this happen i can't
with you yeah i'm new troops my son
ought to find it
[Music]
[Laughter]
so amazing neil two dollar super chat
stop snitching shirt enlarge please no
we are not making sony stop stitching
shirts got you guys black right on the
low just hit me
that is
all of a sudden it appears on the store
tomorrow
he's going to do what he did last time
[Laughter]
xbox gonna be playing 21 savage snitches
and rats outside sony headquarters jail
it's crazy right there
then we got jean-marc louis two dollar
super chat sega screaming now that
that's some karma mother effort
let it happen
let that fight
[Laughter]
you thought you could do my job right
how that stupid taste
all you got to do is say i was right and
keep your pension that's it
wow all right hold on a second let me
see if we got jumped a little bit we got
donna talking with the two dollar super
chat yeah i already screenshotted cog
hashtags uh
oh you snitching yeah they got wet away
dragons five dollars let me chat the
only place i get my name changed and
love it limonius
that your surgery was a success
absolutely
recovery please please man so good to
see you take it easy man he made me call
him immediately yeah i called him
chill up exactly
up like a quadriplegic sure
then we got thx 1138 five dollar super
chat satya to phil about the activision
blizzard acquisition don't forget the
cannolis leave the gun don't forget to
come on
this time we didn't get the gravy
this is what this is what happens when
we take too damn long
here we go
let me play with you
five dollars over that song if i can't
play with your joystick can at least try
your platinum
wow
yo
stop snitching on ellis
[Music]
no no we got to take it a little further
than that we get a saudi stop stitching
shirt we sent it to college
yo y'all wallet
one don't give him that time keep going
yeah baby five five dollars
i think sony was the whole monitor in
ps298 in brownsville brooklyn back in
the day still telling wow y'all really
taking
this would be bang bang
topic gang early so um yeah just two
quick one shout out to jeff grubby grub
idols wants to come back to uh
deus ex which i spelled correctly um and
they said they want to do what cyberpunk
27 77 couldn't and they said well uh
reportedly they said that they're
looking to deliver more polished
experience they hear about um that they
want to bring back the franchise so that
was the first bit of news and then the
second bit of news is i want to shout
out
little man little man series s microsoft
gives xbox series that's more memory to
improve graphical performance and
there's a new uh series s sdk out and
microsoft give dev team talking about it
gives developers more control over
memory which can improve graphics
performance and memory constraint
condition so just two little things that
came out no lose bits we'll just fly
through real quick attic on your topic
on idols and deus ex and series s little
man get a little bump
i don't really care about the series
that's
no it's not that it's just after the
series s i refuse to have the lesser
platform anymore like after that gears
five fiasco i wonder what you mean on
one to one s with the one
iteration of whatever system is being
sold
i mean it comes down to it like
especially with the dell x thing um
i think that this we're going to see
scenarios like this is why i'm glad that
square enix sold all those companies
because i don't feel like they were
going to ever let them make another one
so maybe hopefully
um who who
it's not a thq nordic i don't think
they're under that brand they're under
bracer embracers yeah under the same
company yeah
but embracer hopefully you know they'll
actually fund them to make it i'm hoping
that like they actually give them the
proper fun you see well i'm worried
about like these these publishers that
have been known to make double a games
i'm worried that they're going to try to
make that game a double a
game you know what i'm saying right
that's the only part i'm worried about
it's just like because it does cost
money to make a game like that to evolve
it and if they're coming out there
saying stuff maybe they're doing that to
try to
you know get engagement to show them
right here look this would sell if you
just let us make it i hope they let them
make it because i love that franchise uh
you know we'll have to see we'll have to
see you know i actually have both of
those games i have the achievement for
not killing anyone in the entire time
that's nice stealth i like that
i like that no doubt soft that your sex
might be back in the street said little
man with an sdk bump what's that
i mean deus ex coming back after that
said that we're gonna shelve it right is
exciting if that is the case um
specifically not to not to challenge
whatever you know what cyberpunk did or
didn't do okay i think those are two
very different games like my my hopes
for cyberpunk before it came out were
that we're making that sort of immersive
sim as an rpg and taking you know the
groundwork of deus ex and even expanding
upon it more and that that's that wasn't
necessarily what that game is so to see
deus ex maybe come back and try to you
know take that crown again with the
immersive sim stuff is cool
but i'll be honest man like the the
other games that are in their stable
that they could bring back that i'd be
more excited about right now
like a thief the
thief 2 is is one of the greatest
immersive centers we don't need that no
not 2015.
i think we i i wanna
rub it over at
it i would prefer to see a tetris one
through eight oh maybe structure
how many how many games of steve have
you ever played
here's the thing how are you gonna
expect me to expect something different
when i played one game
but i'm gonna tell you that game is the
the old ones are better than deus ex
okay
you need to blame the last developer for
me spitting on that idea exactly
okay for the receiver
do do your due diligence young man
i'd rather i'd rather take i would say
that i'm speaking
and pluck my eyeballs out before i play
another thief
we'll put a patreon uh
for you plucking your eyes out
that seems illegal by the way
oh no okay so beyond that's fine that's
why i get that um honestly though i want
to see legacy of kane come back
thank you see that i had to appeal to
the young man
favorite baby give me a victory
so okay that's cool like it's cool i'm
glad they notched because
you know they had said it was gonna be
it was gonna in the bushes for a while
so you know the fact that they've been
working on these old franchises i'm
happy about that um now the the series
that stuff that's very cool man i mean
they said hundreds of megabytes more
in terms of for graphics performance
right
a lot of games you know it was initially
touted as this 1440p system
and a lot of times it's more like a
1080p system and that's fine uh my thing
is getting those games the majority of
those games to
run at 60
is the most thing so i know they
specifically spoke about graphics and
improving the graphics but at the end of
the day that memory could be used for
performance as well i'd rather be
performance exactly so on that console
performance is key if you're hitting a
60 on everything
with again it's it's eight megabytes
eight gigs of like ram you know what
right but you know what's all i have an
ideal that we can speak more about
ideals later you know you got to stop
saying ideal because sinister hates that
you don't say idea
you keep doing it to bother him and i
get the reason he wants me to say ideals
and i understand why i'm saying
so that's it that's it like honestly
yeah it's cool it's cool because you and
you're going to see these improvements
right
and maybe at some point we see an even
smaller series s which would be crazy
nah no doubt
lord king
dead sex little man with a little bump
bump where yeah
um i love deus ex uh um i i always love
that franchise so the fact that
when i was playing cyberpunk
this just looks like a bigger deus ex
yeah um to be honest with you and to me
i thought deus ex did it better
so for them to look over and say
cyberpunk
copied us in a bigger world but didn't
do it better
let's get out there and show them how it
should be done all right let's let's do
it let's see
competition breeds uh excellence so
let's yes
so this this is what i want i i'm not
gonna go into what they should be doing
they're talking about this specific
title so yeah let me let me get this
because i like this i i i do like des x
and i do feel that there's room for
uh improvement when it came to uh
cyberpunk yeah now shout out to jason
ronald
little known fact uh when the
development kits mature they send out a
patch anyway
a lot of those games are 120 frames per
second on little man and 60 frames per
second so
what they were listening to was the
developers talking about the graphical
differences between the series x and the
series s and there's any way that the
memory constraints inside the box can
change exactly what's going on i've
always say just jason ronald is a wizard
his team is is phenomenal
the the people at microsoft
listen to what you say and they try to
engineer a way around it either software
or physical
yeah it's a marvel to look at
the little man
right at the size the form factor
everybody you know laughed at it and
talking about it the generation back
right why would you you're going to
confuse the audience the consumer
remember that and it's not because the
audience is not confused they know that
this console
fits them i have four books in my house
and
they fit what i asked them to to be as
you know series x as well but i'm only
saying this that
if you're giving the developers more
without raising the prices
without asking the consumer for anything
that's not a negative
and that's all they've been doing
they've been quietly working in the
background to efficiently show you that
little man has actual value and he is
not a barrier in this generation this
generation is not being held back by
little man
little man has more
120 frames per second games than uh the
stronger competitor and actually has
stable 60 frames per second games
equal to the competitor that has a
stronger uh
console
or more powerful whatever however you
want to do it so to give the the
developers the ability to use the
utilize the memory inside to get what
they want to achieve out of it i think
that only shows you that they are
they're listening they want to be more
versatile and they want to push this
stuff forward so no this is fantastic
stuff when i saw it i was like wow
they they're quiet that don't mean that
they're not working right yeah like i
said i'll just jump in of their sex
that's cool to hear i'm excited i know
shout out to grub who broke it and then
shout out to jason schreier who actually
said he does think it's a long ways away
like it's like rare early they've got so
much stuff going on but it'll be cool to
see it come back especially now that
they're gonna be most likely would
embrace her when that deal closes i want
to see the title is extremely ambitious
say hey if you want to put your chest
out and say what you gonna do with
cyberpunk hey do what you gotta do i
want to see it with a with a budget and
whatever i'm really impressed with i
give a little man that's flowers i'm
really impressed with little man you
know there's a lot of skepticism in the
series that's first of all and let's be
honest cause it's very risky to do a
dual skew approach yeah you know people
were concerned like yo is this the right
play
are you going to confuse it like
remember there was talk that who would
even want the series s as the x being
the more powerful robust you know why
would you you know do this kind of thing
basically the people have spoken yeah
the people have spoken and like you said
you know there's a lot of people who
necessarily neither don't care about the
4k aspect first of all the design of the
console is absolutely stunning it is
when you own a series s it is really a
beautiful piece of tech it's small it's
like shout out to all those people in
japan yeah
yeah went out and brought it and then
i'm gonna be honest ever since i got
that x screen little man's with me all
the time when traveling i take that
thing on the plane airport hotel
whatever and i still are playing my full
experience the way it is so it's a
technical ball man so put the little
man's in the chat i got to give him
flies but yeah i love anything to give
more resources because that was the only
thing people was like yo maybe a
bottleneck yo you know
some devs are having issues giving them
the tools that they need to maximize and
getting the most out of it is awesome
because one thing i did like is they
make at least a chip set the same that
was my main concern because i know with
um addict was talking about with the 1s
and the x you talk about a whole
different you know what i'm saying yeah
jaguars or whatever but um yeah he's
doing his thing and then last thing is i
don't think people are sleeping people
are sleeping on the remarkability of
little man because look at that four
guys castle look how like it's cute you
got the little ah like you could get
creative with it it's such a cool
looking
they got one man they got what i it's
cool to see and i think as we talk about
call of duty to generation and stuff
like that you're going to see them get
creative and do packets cause that to me
when you win in regions that you've
never done before like japan and you
talk about trying to win a generation
and that to me is an entry point for a
casual gamer that doesn't want to bust
his pocket doesn't necessarily care
about all his 4k stuff so yeah shout out
a little man shout out to the team they
did their thing i just wanted to give
them a little flowers on that but that's
all i got
you want to do the supercharger through
the pole you're going to pull then you
get a supercharger
yeah do the pole let me just run back to
make sure that you don't need me to to
go back
[Laughter]
like i was saying
all i gotta do just throw this back on
get right back into the video
new iov phone with the recent response
by sony the regulator stating that xbox
only call of duty has no rival it could
influence console choice then microsoft
telling regulators that activision
blizzard doesn't produce must-have games
whose stance do you more closely align
with the choices are a sony stance is
most accurate b microsoft stance is most
accurate or c i don't care we all sony
and microsoft both trying to finesse
defense
everybody who rocked the iop phone last
week an absolute pleasure shout out to
the legendary jason i would go for i
think probably
one of our best
oh i mean we've had some that was
that was something and we've had so much
there's a lot of nuggets yeah he drop
dropped some yeah man salute salute to
him man chad was on fire he was on fire
it was it was a good show i love
everybody the energy everybody so salute
to that but uh sorry we'll give you
super chats
we got splendiferous two dollars which i
hope you bout to be on jim's hit list
the king is first
you don't want a squabble
first of all i ain't fighting no
snitches oh
cause all he's gonna do is
[Laughter]
amazing deal two dollars super chat sony
aka master splinter your adventure
there we go stitch 5 super chat i think
sony's statement was very disrespectful
to their own studios stating they can't
make a game as good a
and disrespect your team
they got guns and i ain't got nobody
that can help
better get that more phone go ready yeah
oh my god
then we got flame two dollar super chat
the way [ __ ] spelt it and the title was
due sex
let's do sex it was i don't know what
y'all
it was correct all this time if you
think about it
sony went over to bungie
i need you to help me in this fight
coming up yeah and then went to the
regulators it was like i ain't got
nobody
literally walked up to them and it's
like imagine like naughty dog all
insomnia popping was like we ready man
we ready nah i i i i contracted for this
go go go go back do what you was doing
because you can't help here
gotta take this crazy we got uh amazing
neil two dollars so we chat sony aka
karen
wow
man we are caught up with good no doubt
lloyd addict where can i find people
find you what you got going on sir
you find me on twitter at lord addict
iop you can also find me
on youtube at gaming i'm gonna try to do
more live streams here
trying to pull more reviews but you'll
put in the chat would you guys like me
to review because i'm looking at all
these games and i'm not gonna lie like
there's only a couple of that entitled
that like interests me i do kind of want
to
play saint ro but then part of me is
like do i really want to play saint ro
i'm probably going to review destroy
humans repro uh the two repro
components yeah because it's two players
i like to play with you
i remember back in the day like you
could like level up your ship where you
could like
grab cars and throw them and like i i
want to do stuff like that see that's
what i'm worried that they're going to
do x because it's just like you look at
something like that that is a game that
you don't feel like they don't have to
put a whole lot of money into you know
what i'm saying like because you look at
destroying humans and it's like
that is the definition of like a really
solid double a game and it's just like
when they picked up like tomb raider and
stuff and i'm just like i love that they
got them away from evil square enix
but it it's just like are they gonna let
them im properly fund them to do what
score enix was doing because regardless
what kind of bad rep scoring it's got
for how they were handling that company
they did fund them
they just didn't like anything yeah i
mean they're saying embrace or they they
haven't they're making triple a games as
well right so that's what they said
anyway i don't know what you know
budgets budget-wise what that means but
they said there's going to be triple a
games as well sorry would sell 10
million copies or something you know
what i i think this was good
15 mil like why didn't we do 15 million
so you know definitely look out for that
uh we do have merchandise that should be
coming up here in the next couple weeks
uh it's just it's time consuming guys
you don't uh we gotta have someone make
it then we gotta go back and forth on
how we want the actual
artwork to look there are new products
that isn't teespring that i'm probably
gonna work with king to to get they have
like new like shorts that they got new
new stuff that takes like the entire
area of your shirt
of your shorts so i do want to take more
advantage of that and they got a lot
more women wear because and i do feel
like we don't have a lot of stuff for
women i mean i'm sure that we probably
only have a couple percent of people
that follow us that are women but we we
we do need to do better on making sure
that you guys got stuff to buy if you
want to agree so we are looking into
stuff like that uh like i said i will be
most likely
next
week next month it's just ridiculous
with the games that are coming out
right and then you and then not to
mention next year next year
this next six months is probably the
best gaming's been in a long time like
it's it's ridiculous especially if
starfield and redfall actually come out
during that first part of the year like
they say they are like
oh god of war next year
yo no you did not say that gotta win
next year you know what you know what
king
you triggered my trap card
i'm done
you didn't just you didn't just answer
my call to your call
that's right buddy i got that too
anyway
look what's up we're gonna figure out a
war is definitely coming out
yo
you ain't got that right there
i do but i changed it to this
oh wow i'm done they that they talk
about us extending the [ __ ] yeah
anyway
i got to go to work so you know you can
find me there but you know you'll find
papa gabe and the steam deck with me so
weekly segments of your time with the
steam deck yeah that's fine but what
along with the steam deck
but along with the steam deck comes like
you see this is where you fail to
realize that
i i'm up in my game elsewhere along with
the steam deck i am home sometimes right
so then i'm gonna have the 30 90 ti
and then what you gonna say then what
you're going to say oh no no you know
now he's it's that it's not the same
alan now i'm ashamed now i'm ashamed
okay he's shaving the crew down
we're talking about the
that coffin
you just want me to talk about the 30 90
version of the game
the 30 90 no steam deck's cool i guess
like
it's not necessarily anything to do with
you saw but like the same people that
like clowned on like
which games now they're all about i've
noticed yes i've seen some of that
narrative online that's so that's funny
it's just like to me and she's like dude
at the end like 30 fps is fantastic like
see i've seen i'm like i don't mind
playing 30 frame games if i have to if i
have to i will play that but i'm not
going to like
demand 60 and then go to a platform that
doesn't yeah no no i'll tell you this i
mean i spend that's why i'm tweaking it
so much because you know i'm not really
about that 30 on that steam deck either
you know what i'm saying actually now
these dudes are going to complain
because they did four hours but yeah
it's funny that's funny it's like
it's too long
they sit there
i love it it's great so yeah that's it
that's what i'm gonna do i got work
today so let me read these two super
chats quick get them out of the way no
not get them out of the way but get them
get us moving yeah
still going by choice
five dollars somebody's a quarterback
that said my offense sucks and wonders
why they start getting sacked great show
salute
then amazing deal two dollars super
chat's still crying laughing oh my god
thank you bro
tell a friend tell a friend hit that
subscribe hit that like y'all make sure
y'all
that membership gift from work man yeah
let's see how that's oh that's right we
got that feature we've seen it a couple
of times yeah we have people have uh
let's see how it works
i gotta see it again
i gotta see it again i don't remember
how it works
uh it looks like anyway
[Music]
exactly where you find me you can find
me not in the witness protection program
that's what you can do and you can find
me holding my head up high as an xbox
consumer
you know what
i'm not talking about
[Music]
no more man you know this shades is for
the dudes that's in the witness
protection
you know listen man
we gotta see who you are
and you you you dudes is looking mighty
funny man yo i've never thought i'd see
the day
king is definitely blind he sent me a
screenshot and his texts are like this
yeah i love it
[Laughter]
and i like the squabble yeah why are you
shooting me unlike sony but yo a young
son
i i would never have thought
that this young brash dude that was out
there knuckle busting fighting taking
names running in people's houses pulling
people down doing all the dirt in the
streets
at the end of the day as soon as he get
mopped in his mouth he was gonna sit
there and start pointing things out
and giving up the whole organization
since when we do that
damn i thought this was like close to
the nostril i thought
out
you dudes is breaking all the rules i
don't on all honesty i don't know how
you sony dudes can wrap these dudes like
this
and don't ever come at me talking about
sony got bangers
i got rats oh
man
you got cheese
so i don't ever i
this is an indictment again
paperwork that came out
100 people
i got to do paperwork i got your
paperwork we saw you was in brazil
we saw you was out there snitching
yo how everybody in the room may say a
word for you
and everybody can put everybody looking
at you like your come on
this is he and this is how i know it
ain't gonna be a playstation 6.
the playstation sold in the hood
the hood don't rep no rats
you're done in the hood
so
i guess i guess you're gonna have to
sell to the
run with the suburbs oh my god are you
done out here right now you're gonna be
at the gas stations they're gonna be
selling playstation five at the gas
stations yo how to thug you know i feel
so sorry for the scalpers that got these
playstations
[Laughter]
you're not selling because you're
snitching stop snitching the shirts is
coming out cool
this is the movement
yeah and i'm lord cognito
and this is another episode
of the king and the other guy king of
the other guys podcast i'm just happy to
be here let him get his bars off man
what
[Music]
what is the new sony stop stitching
merch coming out
okay you got anything else
all right cool all right we outta here
we see y'all next week
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you